just out of curiosity do you guys like
this starting soon screen just just want
want that feedback in the in there in
the chat yes
you
put a 1 in the chat if you can't wait
for combat talk
you
the show's gonna start seeing you guys
definitely you know if you like this
starting sued screen put that in the
chat cuz we're getting a little bit more
people in here we definitely want the
rails feedback
you
Cory Hale bus love Lord Cory here with
the final super-super chat works alright
you work it out the kicks in I
appreciated Lord Cory hell thank you
brother
we'll be getting ready so 60-inch at the
king is the kick has arrived to deal
with y'all you don't sale but we gonna
get it we gonna get into this soon so
just stay tuned I'll wait for softer
pull up
you
all right
and we hold oh I gotta get the tweet out
we are welcome to the ILO's podcast and
the Lord's gave a dotnet episode number
147 and it's not the glorious Sunday
we're back at the roundtable or the
Lord's Day today we've got the PS fire
pulling out of PAX East and GDC Xbox
series X revealing spatial sound ninjas
it's just a game comments and dreams to
discuss so we're gonna get right into it
so let's introduce the Four Horsemen of
gaming those original Lords of the realm
here at the round table
my co-host my brother from another
mother the Lord of the I'm well rested
today I was scrolling down people's name
and I'm the last person our cold was at
the top but for some weird reason I just
hit the button that is driving
would you be playing sir I've actually
really been playing some stuff on PC
here lately I'm going to get my xbox
back tomorrow so we can actually play
games together we mainly play destiny on
xbox altra theory humbled wild at the
same way Xbox or Humble the PlayStation
next generation you know what I think
you're onto something fraud alert we
gotta grab a game I should look up in
here do extra already waiting for let's
go you been doing I've actually booted
up to switch and then when I hold up
hold up
I'm booted up to switch and I realized
it was dead and what dead and I didn't
put it up again I put a pack of my bags
out the kognito yeah you know those let
joy Khan's mess up all the time
incognito sent me an extra one that he
had kognito had done more for the
Nintendo switch that apparently the
switch the Nintendo's will do aaron
greenberg
his promotion game is Ilse he said your
control looky looky looky we have
Gaylord the solo gamer who lives for the
single player selfish experience and
also the sastra Damas mr. offline
profile Illuminati and lower-paid short
of the iron baked mommy North sovereign
are you doing sir what's going on sir
doing good man doing good I was a little
under the weather earlier in the week
I'm over and done with so we'll get to
that later to playing some more that
Star Wars the worlds that respawn man
respawn ghosts the world that they have
crafted for this game like you just
don't expect to see it right this this
whole thing with the Zephyr I don't know
how people don't not feel in this stuff
you got to the Colosseum thing yeah yeah
I got to that part you know I really
enjoy a lot of those types of games like
Dark Souls they have like you know you
have a lot of backtracking but and the
in that game you have a lot of
backtracking but they make you take
different ways back different
opportunities have you do it in a way
like a good man it doesn't feel like
your back track exactly because you're
always finding new routes and you've
seen different things that you weren't
able to see before
with Metroidvania yeah yo oh man I'm
loving it I'm absolutely loving it oh so
last week yeah I forgot to talk about I
hadn't dreams last week I got into
played I finished the story mode and
actually I wanted to ask Jason if he had
had a chance to see it and what he
thought that's right about the I forgot
but ya know did you want you know
you probably said I'm not into free
labor nobody preaching my food now
before we get to kick which everyone is
waiting for did you get a chance to
[Laughter]
support such conduct further adieu
what's up your intro then we'll do our
thing and then we'll go on a combat ok
no doubt ok
and of course we have the Incredible
Hulk of this aka
the XS gamer the Lord of combat sports
king of the statues who demands nothing
less than that premium experience it is
the leader of the fraud alert movement
who beloved Lord King they are waiting
for you how you doing Bloody Sunday
right you offer that respect me a fall
back respect you see that right hey you
you see this god I never scared the God
now left with the king let me explain a
couple of things go in and our state
coordinator so what we heard you know
things are happening you know got tweets
about dragons showing up on I ope you
know a lot of things going on man but uh
would just add rough-road do the drum
room
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
sorry I was muted you could talk and we
are like a shadow to the graphic guard
holding the realm down order to do some
nice little special thing for your older
supporters and around the subscribers
the patreon
man this is what we try to do it try to
improve the show as much as we can so I
hope you like the new digs in the realm
if you know this is all because you guys
all the support you come up here weekly
and give us all the the love you guys do
in the super chests the likes the shares
you know all of this we did all this you
just give you guys a little bit more to
look at yeah I think something at this
important to say about you know all the
support you guys give us weekly and none
of nobody nobody here is taking home
anything for themselves so everything
comes in let's give you guys a little
bit of our new features ok see see the
topics there you know we can make those
glow yeah you know what King does his
little frog alert I I can I can do this
fried alert and then you know we got
that bin the knee we got that going on
we got the you know the bushes you know
we got that yeah we got the coming in
hot give me that coming when we get this
I need to see that Smitty Smith to the
Lords media in the building be a lot of
fun we could be added what
again I am Lorde salute to the graphic
God holding it down you know I'm saying
but what I further do now that we got
all the hills and all stuff out the way
but this one intro that we had to get
going what's up can you guys tell me
what to put that fraud alert on man I'll
do it oh yeah what's going on King man
in first in the world to combat swore to
me that combat talk recently that is
amazing fight and the realm wants to
hear your opinions what's going on man I
saw you come in with the hate me now
let's go so let's get into it right you
know yesterday the world was watching
the heavyweight division the world
stopped and took a notice you heard
sovereign said you know not even
watching me yesterday boy all right
let's give a shout out to the two
heavyweight champions there for last
night who stole all the I mean you know
the fact that nobody on the undercard
was really of any supernote you know it
was the worst undercard I've ever seen
for $79 because I kick I'm not going for
him I watched your little video cuz I
was thinking to say shout to sedgwick
age thank you brother salute to you
lords said you agent $10 super Chad
thank you brother
all the Fonz tweeted this out tell us
something the Lord's have evolved love
the gold love my brothers here on the
panel thank you for all that you guys
give you guys have no idea how much time
we spend how much this this was a very
this is a very long process we had to
make sure we got everything right for
them for the round we had to so we made
sure they do it you know so a lot of
things you know if y'all saw
combat talk this week and I picked
Deontay Wilder name you also understood
I told you did he lose in this fight
when it happens
so we all knew going into this fight
Tyson Fury was the superior boxing's
it's all the biggest well not stronger
Togo taller bigger more skilled man you
always see this is a rule of thumb you
always go with the bigger skilled guy
like you but you know big guys fighting
on two guys fighting always go with the
larger skilled guy right and that's the
rule of thumb one thing that Don
Deontay Wilder always has is that when
racer when you touch the head get
feverish in his over because mr. glass
it deforms a little low attic you said
you told us up a little bag yeah turn us
up a little bit could do yeah I'm switch
up so when it was fighting for the first
three rounds
Deonte it was looking like how it's
going look yeah it was looking just like
the last fight didn't honest with you
and then um a freak accident happened
I said fury through a one two and yon
they went to block their one two with
his left hand up the right hand slipped
over the back and hit him in the back of
the air blew his eardrum oh gotta bleed
him profusely no equilibrium done he was
done at that point
right no I don't want you I can't state
this enough cuz a lot of you frauds have
never been in a fight
alright so when you get punched in your
face hitting your body when you getting
hit period it takes a little something
again it's a lot easier to say
you could've did this you could've did
that when they Journal run with your
body
they wasn't doing it yeah he got hit
air drum blown I saw it it broke my
heart right there
yeah and I said the king is in trouble
yeah I said so he's going to need every
last bit of energy he has around that
ring to keep him going look this big boy
was on top of him and a Greek boy was
working them oh yeah no fury fury was
doing what a fury was supposed to do
wounded animal you take that animal out
right and I do say this you got to give
all respect dude to Tyson Fury for doing
exactly what he's supposed to do
Thanks he's a he's a great champion he
took a great champion he took out one of
the most feared news but I had some
frauds on my timeline talking about oh
the first time he fought us a stiff
challenge cause mm he folded fold for it
mm he did not fold that champion stood
up on his feet his towel his his corner
threw the towel in on him sure he was
taking punches but at the same time that
towel was coming in he called fury with
a left hook and he said whoa he was
still the champion he is as he left hmm
understand he had a broken jaw at the
badge always said he was broken he had a
torn ligament in his leg and he had a
blown eardrum yeah boy he fought his
heart out so just carry I'll say I saw
you on Twitter yesterday I don't watch
boxing at all but from everything you
just said torn ligament what else did
you say yeah so out of everything you
just said keep why don't you still don't
believe his quarters should have throw
in the towel this is the part that I'm
going to address let's get to it all
right
when before you go in the ring I'm gonna
give it to you guys if you never fought
or anything are you going to ring set
prayer mm-hmm so he was dead is the
fighters prayer mmm you know may we both
go out the same way we come in right but
if anything happens it's better him than
me
mm-hmm okay so he knows they're going in
he's ready to die going in you did tell
someone
him being took out in the stretch it's
like he has laid many men out some
nights is your turn you know some nights
is going to be your turn but you go out
on your shields you don't want no weak
dude talking about your crits my eardrum
you mind my ears I feel a lot of champ
this is wrong king let me you something
it is so wrong
so gladiators it millions of dollars for
your entertainment so what what point in
time is this not wrong then and now is
they were screaming for blood and you
want pillows so hold on that wing was
soft
I said sauce self and go watch something
like fluffy like you expect them gloves
I do go into motion for you King
obviously we're not gonna from what I've
seen
we can't criticize his character his
character is good he was there he was
willing to die in that ring but what I
want to know from you King you will have
been beneath to your decision say whoa
it's a little brother but appreciate it
let's appreciate it oh you know
obviously you are the combat tour expert
and for me you know you know how I bit
down on box the last couple years so to
see this type of spectacle first of all
let's shout out to the event you know
having a spectacle having Holyfield
Tyson Louis tag the error that I grew up
with you know I'm saying kind of be
celebrated and these are the new
generation dudes you know so for me I
looked at the joy and I'm like okay look
this looks like it's gonna be at least
these two are perfect dance partners
right one guy could end the fight at any
point and the other guys kind of a more
skilled guy so when I looked at it
coming around see how it's going how
it's gonna play out now I'm with you you
don't say it you know in the beginning
started off whatever now this is where
I'm with you on the part that if you get
your eardrum blown like cuz I knew some
was wrong with him like I was like yeah
why he everything he was like falling
down and coming off over every day and
I'm just like okay so but seriously well
and then I don't know he was like do you
see this movie kept doing this every
time they kept splitting sawed off like
he would yeah it was just a double check
he's alive it was just weird but no I
don't wanna take nothing away from Tyson
for it I was a masterful performance he
did his thing you know I'm saying
and I guess the question though is do
you think cuz I get on before outdoor
you did get gonna do number three or do
you think it's gonna be now Joshua and
they gonna tear the roof down with some
real UK first UK let's get her first we
don't know if Deonte is okay that is
true we have long-term damage I ran out
the white shot the wife you for rubbing
his leg during the whole say job he got
a ride but when you when you have a
promotion of this caliber there's no
pulling out you know it's trauma to the
fraud Tim Bradley I would call you what
I was calling you all night
um with the behavior you know Tim
Bradley is there for Yasser Boston on so
big shout-out to the fraud Tim Bradley
but I remember when Tim Bradley had both
his a little ankles splashed out and
time and Pacquiao toys freaking head off
remember when that happened so no
excuses then Tim don't make no excuses
now
King he stood up he didn't go down but
by giving all over the place don't
remember that door you know what I don't
like is the flip-flopping I don't care
if you like fury it's two men going in
picture champion well if your champion
when your champion when so who cares a
champion but I'm a robbed with my
champion just because your champion I'm
not gonna change sides
don't flip flop like that I've rolled
with the new all the way to the next
fights coming up right you say he has
the WBC belt Joshua got his belt back
from getting his butt whipped by the
Pillsbury Doughboy if Tyson Fury was to
fight Joshua Joshua would never take
that fight i'ma tell you
he's not gonna take that fight he has a
fight lined up right now he's fighting
another tomato can that's the thing go
well he won't fight Tyson Fury Tyson
Fury is gonna fight the mandatory for
the WBC belt his um as his name escapes
me right now but it's a one-man right
here so you're gonna fight the mandatory
now later we had three more fights on
his docket before now so that first he's
gonna find a mandatory yeah fight in
that mandatory you say Deontay Wilder
should be getting ready to fight or has
a scheduled fight coming back he's gonna
have two fights on his belt before he
comes back
the last fight would not go back it's
not gonna happen straight away the last
fight on the ESPN contract with Deonte
well I mean with Tyson Fury will be
Deontay Wilder III I no doubt we got to
be just real quick shout to the frogs
dream with the file on super to go he
said the same thing I said shout-out to
King's wife for keeping the Veals of oso
point she does that for you I love to do
look Wilder can always fight again and
then we got we got that's off restore
Hades restoring Hades with the Tanakh
super Chad just want to say good morning
to the lords I also want to say I love
the new setup and appreciate everything
you guys do for your fans
I'm going to the show Wow in turtle
should die file on a super chat the
fight reminds me of Canelo vs. Chavez Jr
it was like that toy punching bag swing
back and forth while the knees to learn
ring movement more because you know
that's my guy we go back and forth and
stuff and we can
cat on Monday about that eternal um it's
it's not the same you know it's it's not
the same in that in that regards you
know you have to affect an injury it was
a beautiful fight but I want you saw
Evander Holyfield standing in that ring
right now when you fought Riddick Bowe
and he was out on his feet had they
stopped that fight we would have never
saw the great spectacle that is true you
know this is why you supposed to let
that champion go out on this year we
don't know if Deontay Wilder makes it 12
rounds you don't know we don't know
anything but what we know is the corner
stop the fight and the referee comply
with that the referee was gonna let it
go cuz the referee his front and role he
sees everything so that's let's tone it
down it's nice to be quarterback Sunday
morning right and I agree with something
on the awards say it was like well it
feels like Wilders corner like Walder
has improved immensely since he started
I still not a fan of his in-ring you
know Amelia besides the punching power
in the heart but we'll say that it felt
kind of like those last couple fights
he's plateaued like he's he's learned
he's learned the importance of the jab
and he using but he still falls back on
the one punch you know I
and I'ma be real soft I don't like his
defense with the head go back oh that's
the people like that Oh puts his head
back in a position where these guys he's
fighting with Long Reach just like him
yeah straight Oh exactly knocking
trainer he's like that that I feel are
sort of basic boxing things that he just
needs to get in his mind and it's one of
those things like it's hard to teach
teach someone you know this how I feel I
saw it I know you go ahead right the way
I feel is like he's like the LeBron like
in a sense of he's just so naturally
reunited it's physically talented and
it's like he it's hard to tell someone
who's been so dominant without pure
basic funding from these right should
now change up because how you gonna tell
him he been 49 and new and I'm saying
like it's hard cuz his success he like
you I'm gonna get you or guys get you
one so I just I just hope whoever when
they go funky never
- you know what anybody wants him to be
he doesn't have to just want him to go
in the dojo and just add maybe one or
two little wrinkles lesson a repertoire
because he's close to at the very least
be able to put him in a better position
and still have it's like to me it was
like a fighting game where one person is
charging up his super the whole time I
would do got the whole full move you
know like you said he already has this
skill set his style is already set he's
the older guy in a ring we're not gonna
get something a bit obvious love aside
dude that little crop the Crocker used
to take dude who trained Tyson Fury oh
yeah yeah this you really see why he
kissed him he gave him the belt
the reason why Tyson Fury was on his
front foot majority of the fight mm-hmm
shout out to shout out shout out to the
yeah his knockouts yes salt Jim teaches
you how to throw that right hand off
their jab and the fury is a great astute
learner of the box and tradition
no more adapt to learn new things not a
wild it yeah you know and you soy in his
repertoire
it changed the body shop yeah no bodies
Deonte with his feet together when he's
got perfectly time shot fundamentals is
off he sits down it was a crazy shot but
it was fundamentally sound your real
quick I gotta get my homie to dodge nine
to five pound super chat love the new
look Lord's fury might have to fight
Dillon white first yeah sorry
Joshua gonna be hiding I reckon
dodge my boy dodge agrees with the kid
you're insane but yeah I had to get you
on that man I know we had a lot more
action please please yeah yeah yeah we
got rain g4 with the $5 super sad
hopefully Wilder will come back like
clubber Lang Smith with the $5 super
chap man he's fraud better stop
disrespecting these those men who step
in the ring
this ain't no game in there that that's
for sure man you talk about combat and
what what King is talking about how you
go out on your shield it's a thing like
I one of my favorite MMA fighter of all
time
mm-hm is a fighter who never set foot in
the UFC
you know Hicks and Grayson Oh Gracie
exemplifies that sort of samurai spirit
where is like you are my brother but the
moment we step into that combat arena
yeah obvious to kill you and I'm going
to fight to that point and you and I
expect you to do the same and the person
the intermediary right the ref whatever
it is their job to stop me or you from
doing that that's the job so you go in
there with the understanding that you're
ready to die and so is your opponent and
yeah with that mentality that goes into
sort of what we're going to talk about
later with with uh with ninjas comments
about backing down and let me just say
this one thing yeah in the arena when
you fight the loneliest person is the
winner
hmm and the loneliest person is the
loser yeah I felt it what all right even
though Tyson Fury had all those people
around him mm-hmm
he was chairing and everybody's chanting
was singing he's the loneliest person of
the fighter knows mentally you're
completely alone this you this is this
is why this is the ultimate stakes you
know you love your little baseball you
know football you love your little
basketball that's a team sport you know
but in this combat stuff it's only you
you see Deontay Wilder had all his
friends and family around him in that
room yeah but he was completely alone
yeah I know Hey I felt it I felt it so
when when these guys fight is a level of
respect you know you gotta really
respect what's happening what's what's
transforming in front of you because for
your entertainment let's say he would've
got hit in the eye and and just died it
happens you know this happens but they
notice going in and have those type of
kione's those type that gospel that go
guys go in it's a different level
different breed and what I don't like
now is this soft mentality that we got
of this generation now these old dudes
we didn't come up on that you know Sugar
Ray Robinson of Freud Patterson these
dudes were certified killers and willing
to go out how they came in facts we got
a move on shout the land so eighty sixty
five subtract King I guarantee AJ
doesn't hide he's been chasing
undisputed his record shows it wilder
turn now fifty million not to fight AJ I
will give you I leave you that last word
for right so we can do right now is um
when it shows up we get better video
game you play tell you guys see it on
the Exxon I got a chance to see it on s
its skill you look beautifully I mean
really nice on the PC it looks very nice
it's a very good looking game I've
gotten out the little fire girl and
everybody almost everybody now yanking
that is probably how all roguelikes
should be made mm-hmm it's it's a very
wonderful game if none of you guys got a
chance to play it please go check it out
you know I've been playing destiny I
know
so you
all over the place he kind of bullied
him the whole podcast no no this is the
one shoe damn I didn't watch it live
because I don't want to be in a chat
going that shoe because he said
respectfully he did not tell you what
was going on and I know you said you are
know the rules if is addict you know
there's certain things y'all know I am
synonymous with so it's like if y'all
know that information drop yeah I know
that texaco yeah yeah oh I gotta wake
him up for this one
by evening addict even you hit me was
like yo publicly chastise my brother he
was out of pocket he he last DLC when um
season is dawn and my man came out to
join and they were talking he was on
y'all
I got the tags sorry you know we're
going to pack this week anyway and of
course we have the game himself the
shinobi long con you know spread never
listen to run with the ILP not tell you
what you want to hear but what you need
to hear so you're like king man that's
the old they oh they shall turn my boy
Bart is a fantastic watch last word is
we miss you missed two hours of him boo
this is bringing a smoke you got it you
gotta watch it go back to watch Cognito
real kognito for your last word was
super lit good to be oh yeah oh just
I've got everything done with a Imperial
foundation just waiting for lasting for
my son my title for my savior title
it'll be my first time I'll be awful and
destiny I'm very proud to get that done
oh I was actually playing place lives on
expose remastered did the first I've
never played game yet you have X cloud
you could play once is that you gotta
get it back I was got a good time with
that rocky and trying to learn that
system whatever whatever and then
finally even though it's mad late King
the s9 has Android 10 when we about to
get that sir
so the only reason why water is now I
can test out remote play for shout out
to the people I to get out of get out a
couple of Saudi dudes because they died
oh you could do remote play you know I'm
saying whatever but I'm like listen if
you have a dual shock for mmm you can't
do it won't allow you to do on play use
it on an on the Android 9 you have to
have the Android 10 operating system to
use it and that's only in the the new
it's for whatever reason you know
Verizon took forever so I shout out
today I got that Gore so I'm gonna do
some testing with that team for worse
like I try to be cute and get the lower
the middle they like my friend some I'm
awesome into the bushes in the chat for
$1400 phone that's what I'll
check it out check it out so I went to
check out first a guy before I got beat
up at the door right and you know
anytime you get beat up you watch a
plane get beat up too so so I try to get
it on the cheap drugs like that fare you
in or you out I'm like oh man only thing
that saved me with your training and
it's great training promotion form is 9
plus so I could bump that up a little
bit to take off and then I got a do the
prorated man I was the 20 plus whatever
I'm doing the [ __ ] ultra you know I'm
saying so yeah we go go all the way out
with that you said the 5g plan that you
get a hotspot yeah now Verizon has this
amazing deal like I said massage the
trade-in they said for an extra $10 a
month for the bill you get a 5 g hotspot
euros this so it is what it is we go to
test that bad boy out
obviously at PAX but at e3 there you go
we're gonna push you to do we go see who
got 5g towers in a city who don't ya
galaxy plush toys you don't say it's not
the bone slave he said 5 G's available
at one time shut the door Russia being
petty you want a fortunate soul you
don't have a phone nah man I got a phone
adieu notable play on my Android boyband
that's what I do that's the game so
anyway now that we got all that stuff
out the way let's get into that poll
last week's poll is also in and the
people have spoken to the question with
the potential manufacturing cost of the
PS 5 at four hundred and fifty dollars
what do you think is the best price
point for Sony if the Xbox series X
retails at 500 the winner of a fairly
competitive three-way ILP poll at 48
percent is the P X 5
at 500m hmm yes then you finish the poem
they are still the bigger global brand
and market leader group yes at it you
and me the fact we ever had the third
option win yeah it's been a long time
it's a little long shot at the big cloud
gaming in the - I had - Lucas lawyerly
no coming in at second place at 28% was
PS 5 should drop to 400 to undercut the
Xbox series X in that last place and
only 22% were closed 22% was I don't
care about no hardware it's all about
these active users know participate in
the poll Lord sovereign what do we think
about this sir yeah I mean I think it's
5 just exactly for that reason I think
they hope right they hope it a name
recognition the global recognition of
the brand right the the goodwill they
think I'm with their first party stuff
this year they hope that carries them
over at the same price point and what we
assume to be a less potent machine than
the series adults don't use Apple
products at the same price point at the
same price point I still think it's
gonna sell more just because of the name
brand put well it will it be warranted
no but I think you know people people
want them exclusives again that's where
they're gonna get them secret child aka
black magic he said Apple is for kids
like Trix
you're black you're black you like that
[ __ ] he hit me early this morning I was
like you know what since we all agree
man let's get some meat of the bushes
for Apple products man I hate up
right there those feet on the screen
that's apples feet they in the stitch
with the - yeah you meet old people
don't use Apple products getting X cloud
only what game would that cloud kids
look in this chat like these these
people we got a console water fold for a
little bit a little forward a baby we
called some more consoles enough what's
two phones for a second folders but if
that's the new battle right - these
times blackboard in these gaming streets
weights what I said it far takes what I
think a mystery so we gotta talk about
it man um Sony a lot of news going on
kid can I set it up when you want to set
it up a lot of stuff going on man so we
got all Sony pretty much pulling out of
PAX East and GDC they made an official
announcement you know they said
basically today so many interactive
entertainment decision to cancel his
participation at PAX East and Boston due
to the increased concerns related to the
corona virus we felt this was the safest
option as the situation is changing
daily we are disappointed to cancel our
participation in this event but the
health and safety of our global
workforce is our highest concern so that
was the first statement and then um
later on not maybe a couple of a couple
days after um they say basically said um
they've got a canceled e they go to skip
the Game Developers Conference so um
they made that they made that notice
that they will not be there now also in
addition to them Facebook is also say
they're not going to GDC now they said
not bringing the oculus rift the craze
of that so um yeah they were very
concerned and then in the last most
recent statement let's be rolling what
was Facebook really gonna show the bags
at the burger to team by deathsinger so
he's pull out game is strong the Boston
mayor didn't as arguments to come back
saw transitions right in so pretty much
yeah then which prompted the Boston man
to make a statement you know his name is
Marty Walsh
she sent a formal letter to Sony CEO
congedo Yashida and I'm pretty much in
the letter he said look man he said he
disagrees with their reasoning for
pulling out he said these fears we
enforce harmful stereotypes that
generation I mean Asians have worked
hard to dismantle they trigger our worst
impulses to view entire groups of people
with suspicion to close ourselves off at
the stop you are speaking truth it's a
missile or the opportunities and
connections our global city provides
Boston is united in our efforts dispel
these harmful and misguided fears and he
said at large Sony had the opportunity
to set a positive example by attending
the show and he said as a leader in
technology you could show that you are
motivated by facts not fear as a leader
in gaming and country you can show that
people believe in connection and not
isolation at the moment sony has yet to
respond so let's bring it to kingston
wedeck
you know what that was a long-winded a
sony eloquently stating you're with the
balance of the deposit the only virus
sony is afraid of and they have is the
money eaten virus
everybody's always looking for telling
you 100 events when is it gonna start
big on just pack it up so you say my
hamsters sick I can't make it
with the mayor of the city it has to
call you out on your BS that's a big L
in range e for two hours a Braille a
corporate solo we got my boy Lord mods
gaming my check my check good I wanted
to bring you on obviously you know this
has been a very contentious topic you
say a lot of people feel strongly you
know either way now me and you have
disagreed on this topic ourselves but we
have respectful discussion you know I'm
saying that's one thing you want to
promote he is respectful this guy
there's no attacking of each other but I
know you're on the opposite side of how
I feel
I feel you're more aligned with a little
bit of line with what Kay you're saying
so I want to get your feeling on it
because you I know you felt very
strongly about this with the whole Sony
you know pulling out at GDC and the let
you go who got them echo somebody cut
they go out somebody got that something
I can hear myself or somebody but uh
anyway there you go so Lama it's like
what what do you feel about them pulling
out both taxis at GDC okay so well first
of all thank you very much for the
invite I always love to chat with you
guys and stuff okay so yeah I mean
that's an interesting topic because like
you know like people are all over the
place with this and this this I think
there is a number of levels to it
because my first of all there's the
virus right and like let's face it
nobody is nobody is trying to downplay
the fact that the virus is contagious
and it's potentially you know can be
very dangerous it's like especially for
LT real people and stuff I mean that's
what a viruses work right generally
speaking it you know when you're sick
you're if you've got already some health
problems I mean that may end up you know
being you know you dying basically right
yeah so but but the thing is like you
know my point my point about the about
all this is that you know let's face it
you know generally speaking you know
here in the West like whether whether
we're talking about United States Canada
probably even Mexico Argentina you know
about like all across the Americas
probably you don't really have a big
problem there right same here in Europe
like you know we don't really have like
you know a lot of people sick now you
know there's been some cases of like you
know a couple of people people sick here
and there mainly those who actually
we're in China and and came back right
but we even had a couple of cases like
that here in Warsaw right but you know
those people were basically like checked
up and
you know you know deal dealt with right
now and I'm not saying that somebody's
gotta you know not that they got killed
[Laughter]
speaking like you know like right now
there's no issue with coronavirus here
in the West in my opinion right now I
get that like you know medical services
and and generally speaking like you like
local governments and stuff they need to
prepare just in case right they have to
have like a danger contingency plans
whatever right and you know I'm sure
that all these hospitals and doctor
practices is that they know how to
handle that right so you know III just
don't like I mean I don't
okay maybe not like I mean in my opinion
like people just basically blow this
thing out of proportion here in the West
right I know that is a problem there in
China but it's not it's not an issue
right now no that's that's the virus now
above the Sonia I made a joke when I
found out that obviously they're not
going right so I tweeted out saying that
also where's those hundreds of events
coming I mean they decided to skip III
and now they pulling out of the you know
PAX East and GDC and stuff right but you
know Jenny like that I understand that
they may have concerns about the virus
and stuff but like maybe I'm totally
wrong on that right now but the thing is
like are they sending people from China
to that - yeah that's the point of
contention that I take you and addicts
share
so you know whole thing is you know
again you understand the virus you know
you understand that portion but what
you're saying is kind of like let's just
leave right into it which is what Square
Enix is doing right where you're right
right where Square Enix is saying okay
we do understand that and we're not
going to send any of our you know Asian
or panel members or those people over
there and just the American team so to
speak so because we know for a fact
we're gonna pax and um the Final Fantasy
seven the American team will be there a
lot of those representatives so you're
just saying instead of pulling out
completely that they should still do
something it's kind of where you're
going yeah I mean like you know clearly
that's doable and and and and and I get
that a lot they are pulling out
so now Facebook is pulling out as well
but at the end of the day like there's
like I didn't check the list of of why
companies or publishers not going was
going to be as fast it apart Firefox
keys but from from them from some of the
podcasts you've been on like I've heard
that you because you go you guys are
going there right right with or um you
know Microsoft's Xbox studio I don't
believe Microsoft has a booth but um
Major Nelson a couple guys ELISA let's
get the chest real quick the preneur
vice as part of Sony's rollout the JD
gamer fireless which at Sony might have
pulled out of packs for the virus but
it's obvious that they pulled out of GDC
so they don't have to face a kiss
Microsoft publicly twelve teraflops so
he's not going to any shows to save
money so they don't lose they sure when
they have to drop the price to compete
with the Xbox series I think that's more
of the truth it's more of the truth and
when it comes to the fact that we
understand that they're having problems
right now financially be pocket is
looking funny as the polls that you
haven't struggles you know getting the
chips that you ordered because
financially they more than you expected
you're gonna get to that bill you ever
go to eat and
and you have the surprise my kids right
you know it says all-you-can-eat
pancakes right yeah and then it says you
know for 95 with the meal in all you get
pancakes so you you expect them five
people you don't know in the moment let
me pay you what I feel like paying you
don't you Sony is at the point right now
with their scrutinize and everything cuz
they got to pay for these chips man they
can't they can't be in a battle of being
got the chips man they're beating I give
it back to Kansas got to be open your
third eye King also knees
JD Gable files which I'm sick of this
dad if that place they should always has
good games they haven't period Ridge
Racer and they didn't start this
generation all for a better game wow
this is real petty hey look before they
give it back the box but I just want to
say alright I hear where you're going
with this but in fairness you don't say
I will get back to about what about the
standpoint of just safety because again
it's not just so neat why why is Naughty
Dog not there why is any contingent from
Naughty Dog coming from overseas where's
their headquarters mine I actually
checked and there's some cases of
coronaries there as well so you must be
right over let's be wrong in in fairness
right let's just say you know I'm saying
in these regions that they are in that
they have you know a hat what case are
so blessed and let's say internally but
if they had a case you know and they're
trying to insulate people from epidemic
Chinese excursion doesn't mean that
everybody else you know I feel a certain
way because I do feel like on one side
you have people like companies like
Square Enix they're located we're not
sending our Japanese developers gonna
send our American developers and they're
still hosting some form of booth there
some things were canceled but you know
the key highlight Final Fantasy seven
that's still being there I if you want
my opinion you know everyone here I
don't know about you Moz but you know
we've all been to events if you go to
the Sony section nine times out of ten
you go up there to ask you know
representative that's beside the game
you want to look at oh you know what are
you a Sony are you Sony employee they
almost every time go to say no they work
for a third party it's a temp job it's
so at the end
they're already been doing this for
years maybe they broke because they
bought and saw me at games they can't do
that this time I don't know but I mean
but here's the thing they had all
intention of going like they I mean we
we saw the booth you know I'm saying
shout out to all our everybody that's
going up with us like they had a huge
present I mean it's not to the very last
minute that they pulled out I gotta say
this to solve I say this all then we
gotta get my laughter yeah how many
times saw that we made plans to go our
member back in the days we used to go to
a loo dude they put me you and a whole
team of people made plans to go out they
went out with us to shop and clothes I
think we're saying because the cancer so
soon is I think some people internally
have maybe gotten this and it's kind of
scared the whole company because you
know you have to put a down payment to
go to these events faint getting that
money back
so obviously yeah that's money loss
they're willing to walk away from that
you know I understand why they're doing
it from a standpoint of health thing I
do personally feel like they can hire a
third party maybe the fact that it's so
soon you can't hire third parties to
companies because it's only like a week
week and a half so maybe that has a lot
to do with it
but I do feel like they have enough
presence in America to go to this event
but you know Who am I to tell Sony to
not look out for the employees right
maybe at the end of the day regardless
of where they have maybe at the end the
day regardless we're happy they have a
presence at you know everyone from
around the world is gonna be flying to
this event they don't want to spread it
any further in their company that it is
and I can't say nothing about that
because it is a serious issue right
let's let miles finish this point yes
okay so
yeah so I'm of an opinion that you know
like in terms of like you know Sony I
think it's it's more about I don't
condemn them for like a not being there
obviously because like you know I'm and
I don't believe that it's it's a money a
money issue right because like like like
you guys said they already paid for
everything so they lost money right so
you know they're not going to be saving
anything like not going there but I
think it's more about like flexibility
and stuff like Square Enix you know
actually is going to be there you know
with basically some other people now
Santa Monica like you know the Naughty
Dog are in Santa Monica right I mean
what would a local local trip right
you know like sure all across without
continent because Boston is I I think is
on the other side of the states right if
I'm not if I'm not mistaken but still
that's a local travel and I think that
the issue is there is just basically you
know that's my belief that what it all
it is is basically the product probably
some internal safety procedures they've
got and they said I [ __ ] it we're not
going to do it language and so basically
I remember because I work for IT support
company for a big security company right
and I was I was on our WebEx with with a
customer without in a huge bank right
right and all I needed
I've made some changes to the system all
I needed is to reboot a bloody server
right it took them five hours right to
go go over through like a couple of
different procedures call number of
managers to make sure that they can
actually just press the blue pin a
bloody button on the server right so I
think it's it might be that Sony have
like very strict policies on that kind
stuff that's why they're not going to do
it but that doesn't change the fact that
you know like you know I know they are
corporation but I guess you know you
know it's it's it's more it's really
about like allowing more flexibility and
stuff right right start instead of like
not going there completely
mmm I mean let's do some let me jump in
because yeah yeah yeah I got I got a
defect the Saudis yeah going in man look
I get it you know for me personally this
was hugely disappointing you know I'm
saying you know the Lord's are being
their lock net is pulling up I mean
everyone that's going on a team knows I
mean we had last of us to ready to go
locked in super pumped for that demo
when we looked at the floor plan
initially they were like I believe it
was like two to three huge soluble
PlayStation had a presence at PAX ease
this was not going to be small so when I
got the news I go fresh selfishly I'm
like nah fam I can't be doing this like
[Music]
I was pissed bro cuz I'm like yo the
Lords of media I'm gonna get a chance to
talk to possibly drunk man or you know
say like I'm ready to get in my bag I'm
ready but still give you out of footy
i'm hype you know i'm saying so when
this hit I'm like damn they couldn't
just you know bring it like you know
bring another representative or why they
had to pull out the whole thing I get it
and then I've seen you know I calmed
down and at the end of the day look you
know say I can't get unreasonable if a
company says look you know we got we
can't act like this there wasn't a
reported case in Boston that was he just
coughed I want you to understand two
things guys a lot of people here I'm not
making light of anything that's
detrimental that's hurting in harming
tons of me all over the world if a
company fails at any point in time that
they're putting any of their employees
in harm's way and then understand pull
out right fine great um but I'm also
saying this and
point in time is it really so many
representatives ever really there they
always have in third party people mean I
talked about this that in nauseam
Viviana you and he was going back and
forth with it with a uneducated
individual about his subject now saying
the guy is uneducated in the world but
this subject addict has first-hand
knowledge firsthand experiences with
what he was talking about all right
oh and it goes to all of these shows and
trust me if he's talking to a Sony due
to somebody you hit that logo on your
shirt
but it's drilling you like so we work
out what are you doing every single
water them says I don't work for Sony
that was the past Dave Dave Dave bad
effort a big strides recently I be
last year we were when we will wit Ben
Studios official Ben we had that days go
on coverage we was rocking with Sony
they were there last year you know I'm
saying like what's the only people ever
at events they were at yes landed we
look at the end of the day you know I'm
saying yes selfishly I was upset but I
get I can't I can't get crazy here's Dez
backed its way I look at its office like
this at the end of the day you know say
like is the Boston Convention Center
Pham mister this is not a cruise ship
this is a convention so if they in the
center of thousands of people all
infected because of a Saudi rep or
whoever from their team are happy to
have it and now that is so many let me
just get this last one yeah there's so
many people in a concentrated space I'm
giving them a pass only for the sake of
safety like I don't want to catch okay
rolling up on me show me his game
he got the wild list you have to keep
the same anymore when it comes to
everything because didn't not all of a
sudden now is the Quran over everybody
there can use the same thing right
everybody use the cardiovert virus is a
problem and mrs. Alma say keep that same
energy so the next time you're going on
date night and they pull out with the
fake excuse we never know business owner
you have you employ hundreds of people
that you employ people you employ me
let's just put that out area some people
baby come from that area you go I
brought a whole bunch of sanitizer hand
sanitizer gloves so when we move around
you see the Lord shirts and you see us
with blue gloves we just not trying to
catch the corona and you know this is
how we movin you know but we will show
up now you're not gonna be wearing mass
on the heavy disrespect but we will know
it's very poor oh please get up y'all
please go okay we gotta go back to a
better game from JT gamer Sony has no
interest in showing up on the dance
floor with my even before then oh okay
so JT game with the father-son chat nah
I'm gonna let that go back to the
PlayStation getting credit for three
great first party games this gen and we
all running around like the king of
games
mm-hmm I love you bro but sometimes the
kool-aid is just too strong he said the
Lord that packs a given nobody DAP just
hang onto a virtual reality if this is
the case right to reveal the PlayStation
anytime within the next couple of months
is it too much right right then it's a
fraud if they all of a sudden have this
big reveal event where they lying in and
when they're lying
journalists and all this stuff no direct
right doesn't it nobody's from JT game
so he has no interest in showing up on
the dance floor of Microsoft out there
only to be found out they can't dance
with the big boys hashtag Microsoft is
not Sega though that little devil so
look this is wit from Philly Eagle I'm
okay I'm a fan of games I want to see
these companies put on
show all these excuses smell like damage
control to me just stop read like three
in a row can you understand why Sony
pulled out okay III oh you know I gotta
read at the bottom of these pulled out
but it seems like people are trying to
make some some feel bad because they're
disappointed other than Sony and Xbox
fans it's not that is it and it's a good
excuse you know why because everybody
wants to say oh you know it is true is
it tragedy happening but we gotta
understand that you know song this is a
real thing so this is bogus bro people
how many people in Boston guide to
Corona one one report again one reporter
case so Sony feels by them showing up to
the Boston they're bringing it they're
scared to catch it you know there's been
a lot of reports in Japan they might be
scared to take it there too why'd that
protect your employees what is wrong so
you
it's protecting the world from their
employees because if this thing is not
there right there's something and they
have people quarantine so maybe that's
the case this is where I will meet you
will saw in the middle aunt Maude's is
that I felt maybe they could have took a
square-enix approach which is just send
American teams there right and
do what squares doing where you stream
what you have to show you streaming a
vicar's fit square is still streaming I
believe what is it final fantasy what's
that final fantasy the arm yeah 14 yeah
so it's not like even though they not
coming up to the panel you know saying
they say they're gonna do a stream
they're gonna still communicate like
just something just a simple you know I
I kind of Millie in the middle when it
comes to them you know come to pax I do
feel like if you know they feel like
their company as a whole is in danger go
ahead and not go to pax but I do feel
like they could hired someone or has
some North America but at the end today
it's not my decisions their decision but
I do feel like them doing nothing to
make up for that is just as bad know
obviously pax hasn't showed up yet they
could do some daring packs you know they
could drop the the demo that they were
going to show on YouTube that pack so
they need something like that to make up
look a you know we ain't at PAX
and we promised you to play but you
can't play but we're gonna pop this on
youtube you could watch it and I think
that would be things we already put that
out there the demo I think well you know
maybe it's not out there
it's the demo that they I guess Prescott
to play beforehand so it's not different
than that remember that time we was
working and they I was Union went on
strike and they had the scab workers
outside this cab workers and they had
the scab workers come in and he did the
job for us because we couldn't do job
shout out the song not even hiring the
scab workers I think in a way this sort
of it goes back to this this whole sort
of centralizing of Sony's power
structure where and not having the
different these different regions have
kind of their own bosses and doing their
own thing autonomously
mmm-hmm it comes back down to this came
down from up on high one character yeah
that's what happened and it trickled
down and that was it so even if it
doesn't necessarily make sense across
the board we for for us-based teams they
wouldn't
necessarily exposed to this stuff it's
an all-encompassing decision right no
matter how kind of again I understand
where you coming from cog but at the
same time when you we look at how how
little it's proliferated over here in
the states in comparison over there in
China it is kind of going I feel a
little over the top it's like I said I
do not think this is a we're gonna catch
this I think this is we might spread
this because there's a lot with the
packs now bra I just can't with the Sony
getting all that credit we need love you
bro understand and even King has said
this right
Microsoft is not the company that people
want we love Microsoft right but as a
whole they're never just gonna have the
worldwide acceptance this Sony that's
not gonna happen so be happy with second
place because I'm gonna tell you why you
would not have all the fantastic things
you have now to talk about the next box
if Xbox won first place right you wanna
got me so be happy where we are
keep them hungry so I say we got another
bundle of super chat from JD gamer stop
handing out all the free credit to the
kings of get clowny than Kega games -
rising zero dong gotta warn spider-man
this Jin they're actually first party X
apparently he thinks Xbox is doing
better besides those three games look JD
at the end of the day I think I think
you have the the the first signs of the
UH at the end of the day you know if we
can't - that cuz they still got persona
5 I love that game even if it's not
first party they still have those I've
said from the start they're getting
final fantasy in a couple months time
exclusives mattered are you sure that
that might be exclusive inside a time
exclusive but there is nothing in that
list that you said that Microsoft has
done to combat those games
I love stay decay - I love Rico I know I
said that I said I love Rico we're gonna
completely ignore that I love having fun
I really enjoyed gas v but but I enjoyed
God award more than I enjoyed all of
those games
Microsoft has done this they went from a
point where people thought this brand
was done like it was lobster where they
can like you they got shot they went to
the hospital now they finally starting
to walk again you don't want them in
first place I don't I don't want I want
them hungry always a real question for
mods I got a question for mods because
you wouldn't want to people that know
showed real concern all right so this is
don't leave your house you might get
mugged you mugging epidemic Mars is one
of the people that showed general
concern we have a chat for you know -
one of the guys that's going to be with
us one of the great men is gonna be with
us in Cali and he showed a general
concern in the chat he asked you know or
we take a safety precautions going
forward Michael you much um and going to
California and being that you know Santa
Monica and all these other places are
really going is a very big place and
they are doing checks at airports and
stuff from people coming in they also
you know stopping certain countries from
coming in without proper checks are you
concerned this III about this virus
going forward because you were one of
the vocal people in questioning that
like you know craziness but in
questioning about our safety and I did
appreciate that well to be honest with
you I'm not really concerned about that
because like you know like you said like
you know I'll be traveling from a
country that is not okay well if
nothing's changes because like okay if
we if we going to if you go you guys
would get like a big problem with the
corona virus then I would proudly get
concerned right like I think sounds
right now right I mean it doesn't
concern me right I'm traveling from
Poland where we hardly
barely had any cases right I'll be
traveling to states which it's pretty
much the same yes you probably had more
cases but hey you know you know us is
like you've got like population of
almost like 400 million people or
something like that right it's like 36
million so just basically a thing of
scale so I'm not concerned about it at
all
I mean at least not not right now right
because there's here's the thing like
well the thing is like you know here's
the thing and it's not really about Sony
anymore right at this point just like I
even tweeted a couple of times about
about it like and it wasn't even you
know it wasn't directly at Sony but I
was like genuinely kind of annoyed with
it with the whole coronavirus kind of
approach people approach to coronavirus
and I get you need to be you know
careful about things and stuff right but
I remember mm-hmm the in 2009 there was
this h1n1 virus it was it was deadly it
was all over the place I'm een like and
basically I remember like in GC I was
yeah but the thing my problem the thing
is like you know I was traveling back
then I was I was actually living in in
EU UK at the time I was traveling at
least couple of of times from UK to fall
in it and bike ride and abuse with you I
mean you know yes there was a virus
somewhere there you know like medical
you know you know people were kind of
like fighting this thing right but you
know did that affect me not at all did
that affect any of my friends family and
stuff no it was like yeah it was
something that I saw on TV now I'm not
saying to not get you know like into not
take any precocious steps right like I
said but let's get crazy over it like
you know what do I get out first thing
in the morning and the first thing in
the morning and the things like am I
going to get killed by coronavirus first
man
Mazz but you don't live in a section of
the world where it's bad it's a bad in
Japan like that's where they live is in
Japan I know that's fine but that's why
that's why I said that like you know
they don't have to send anyone American
there plenty present in there they got
plenty of people over there they could
have went to it but at the end of day
they are it's not like you know only
North Americans and you know people are
on the northern content or going to this
event that people around the world or
going to this event right look and fit
and finish to what mother said I
understand it what are you saying and
then you know I do on the flip side
there the other companies that are still
going right that are still gonna show a
shortage suppose I do understand where
you are coming from that right you know
say at the end of the day it to me it's
an individual and personal decision
whether it's financially based based on
a chair you're saying is another thing
but my whole thing is again do you want
them to be in the center of any
controversy again even if it's the
smallest chance one of their employees
[Music]
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
decision you know I'm saying and at the
end of the day you know I understand but
I understand y'all really do not trying
to minimize what you saying much I do
understand where you're coming from you
know there is a mentality to say hey we
have this much education on it you know
as of right now it's not gonna it's only
one case there it's not gonna affect
that if we take it every precaution
you know saying but the flipside I feel
as a company they have they've earned
the right to protect their employees on
any any type of level on the very
cautious level so that's what I could
tell you about Thunder you gotta respond
yeah I mean like listen I understand
that from corporate level I mean they
may have some procedures and vodka and
stuff you know they are afraid to like
you know get sued or whatever right so
maybe being that's the thing right I'm
like I said I'm working for like big
company that we've got like all over the
place and we are sending people like I
mean no it's not saying that we're
sending people to China s top right but
even I've seen the I've seen emails
about this virus and stuff like you know
what to do if you go into China or you
coming back from China it's done right
you know I've seen those emails as well
right I mean it's up like my company
doesn't do anything at all but like
birth you know next week tomorrow we've
got somebody that is coming from Canada
2008 China on a new products or new IT
products right right you know those
people going to be here for a couple of
weeks right and you know like nobody's
it's actually you know nobody's asking
them you know are you guys sick or
something maybe I shouldn't come right I
mean let's just let's not blow this
thing out the flip side Mars and again
my IT company right my that my
counterpart person who does my job we
have offices because I work nights so we
have offices in China you know they are
restricted right now my colleagues are
restricted to work from home they cannot
go to the office so this this very
there's this different level something
about you're talking about people that
work in China right but again I get it
you know people that that live work in
states you know like you know like you
know like listen at the end of the day I
mean nobody wants to see like Sony
executives you know at pass a parks East
well now it's it's really all about the
last of us part it last of us part two
guys right sono molti dogs are based in
Santa Monica right which there was a
case yeah you've got the case in Boston
you've got cold days the everywhere so I
get it listen I get it I get it it's
just two different mentalities right
some companies are saying to your point
right in the agree with you and say hey
there's just one case this is an
isolated incident let's not use that to
fuel fear and still go I understand your
point and then there's the other side
that said look there was one case so why
risk it so it's just a philosophy thing
it's just how do you view and and what
you're saying is time you're in
alignment with what the Boston mayor is
saying let's not promote fear right yeah
let's not we have the facts I completely
understand your point I really do I just
want to just say the other side too as
to why a company would say well you know
what even if it's just one maybe not
even let's not even to a child let's
just pull back but now this is where I
completely agree with all y'all they and
my opinion should send Elia if you're
not gonna send the American you do a
stream you do some type of thing for
your fan base that you're not coming I
say hey we're gonna do this out of no
time with this other event so unless
you're doing nothing like to see that we
do that JD game superjet nah name the
first part exclusives that don't include
horizon zero dawn god of war spider-man
and tell me what first part exclusives
is better than halo Forza and gear ok so
you want to have the argument while
removing Rob Rob removing the reason
you're arguing for us you you literally
want to compare apples to oranges I
understand is he saying horizon God
award if you take those two games out
which is their highest credit games can
Sony compared exhale ogres and fourth of
with the remaining exclusives that's
what he's saying
quit but they do exist it's not like
[Laughter]
Facebook also baptized GDC PlayStation 5
a series X confer for Tokyo Game Show we
know let's get some shields in there for
JT gamer man carnivorous on God and Sony
not going but are gonna send an outbreak
because no you already read the
squirrely down base 23 became why with
the fight Asuka chant I don't know why
people make a big deal about someone I
go into PAX East when there are other
companies pulling out of other events
also the reason why we're making a big
thing in cog eloquently put it and so
did the mayor they were looking forward
to the big space that they rented out
did they put the down payment and the
pie
and he didn't come back and fill out the
deposit the mayor is looking for the
rest of the money so many people coming
in just for Sony imagine being cancelled
because Sony's not there now now also
you know as far as media goes um if you
didn't know we media but we was bringing
coverage to you yeah so when we're going
out then we're putting on the gloves
when you see me sanitizers are on and
we're we're going out there shaking
hands and kissing babies and taking
videos for you guys and taking pictures
to bring you all that information
because let's say you got to work that
there you can't go out well we took off
for work and we're there for you
so we're making sure that we get that
information for you so the fact that one
of the biggest hitters that yeah they're
not there with the biggest game you want
to play you want to play that last of us
part two just like me I don't care what
anybody says that game is highly
anticipated and we would have got two
different kind of take on a different
kind of information opposed to the
information that they're hand feeding
you we're going to give you the real and
the uncut let's be a little here the
only reason they're getting hit like
they are is because they pulled out of
e3 if they were stuck going to e3 no one
would be saying nothing and to Maude's
wigs i saw miles tweets earlier you know
it has been a while since we've gotten
sony information so I think it's just it
feels like a it seems like every time
we're not getting something we're not
getting so let's get these super Chester
Smith I want you to read that King let's
go I got it carnivorous kind of a risk
on God in them to power super chat I
could sell you packs biohazard suits
as the biggest Anthem fan here first off
let the fraud alert WOM free themselves
don't always equal a good game anthem
out so many so-called good games just
keeping it a hundred subjective I agree
I'll take back the frontal lobe yes this
is 66 days with the finest of a chat
question what if sewing just holds back
for their preview of it just because
they don't have enough to show fades but
how much how long we're gonna run with
this narrative that they keep missing
events because they have nothing to show
that should scare the hell out of you
good ain't got no games then that's just
scare the hell out of you that's just
scare you name what the carnivorous
value terrify you more than anything
else that they have not opened their
mouth put your love how Kings always say
this is just gaming you guys but the
career advice games above that so you
know first I want to say is that brat
brat King hit called with that light
called just man Sony bonus new ps4 pro
light touch subscription to PS showing
up to pax wearing a power armor suit you
know what rap since you put that color
in I'll give him the fraud alert for you
because pony stuff for me they do it all
type of man I got deals behind the
scenes
Crona is gonna mix with the h1n1 and the
Last of Us listen we've been on this for
a minute at the end of the game we got
to move on but listen it is what it is
you know these people are a subset I get
it you know these companies that did
show up I completely understand that
point when Mars is saying and um you
know as far as not fear-mongering and
stuff like that but at the same time I
do understand the sentiment of a company
trying to protect the employees so
hopefully they do announce it
hopefully they do do a livestream
hopefully they do something just to show
a little fan you know favor during this
period of not having a see them thank
you all 255 people watching this live
you guys might subscribe for weekly
shows you know we've been to you're
doing this for a while so if you ain't
subscribed definitely go down and hit
that subscribe button
yeah so we gonna move on to that topic
man we go here right into so just kind
of double feature I'll be quick
on Xbox series x-men some there back in
the news and so it looks like shots my
boy Tom Warren senior editor arm at the
verge and he was asked on visa era you
know when do you think the Xbox series
acts revealed will be and the question
was at e3 because most people assume it
will be there and he said no before e3
so that's the initial where the rumors
right now circulating is that the
PlayStation 5 reveal will be in March
which is next month and that Sony I mean
that a Microsoft will be in April so
that's the latest rumors right now we're
gonna talk about that and then the
second part this is the king king
brought this to my attention
let me talk about some special audio
stuff man so it looks like at GDC
you know there was a little panel going
on that Sam's just gonna talked about
it's called building audio gateways with
immersive worlds with spatial sound it's
at first don't you say like a basic
title it didn't sound like anything
crazy but um it looks like Microsoft
will be announcing some type of arm
hardware and some type of arm audio
features and pretty much what it says is
that through their middleware partners
they kicked off a revolution with
spatial sound that turns any pair of
headphones into a multi dimensional
gateway to another world and yeah
just read something real quickly child
gamer says IOP let us know what they do
with all that Sony space do they leave
it empty put kool-aid in it what is so
big already
you know the Microsoft new special
techniques that they will be putting out
there for the head they said anyone so
this is gonna be a high branch like I
said at this peril you know it says
learn from the audio designers of
Borderlands 3 gears over five and show
us how a Cadillac collaboration between
Microsoft Dolby and their middleware
partners ticked off this revolution of
snus and that's where turn these
headphones any pair of headphones is a
multi dimensional gateway to another
world attendees will deep dive into the
audio design project acoustics the couch
thing is what they call it so on Yammer
so this is the first time we're hearing
about any arm features from audio on the
Microsoft side I know that our mark
Cerny in the wired article had mentioned
how they wanted to do custom unit for 3d
audio for the PlayStation 5 so we'll see
how that pans out so we get some audio
news and we possibly getting a reveal so
we bring this back to the Louis Abdullah
HD in the realm or with this news about
April you know being a reveal what do
you feel about that and then also does
this tech because you are the tech lord
of lords' gave me that neck you know
what this does this tech excites you
about spatial sound Xbox series X robot
yeah I mean any new tech excites me yeah
let's let's start with the you know the
issue event well yeah this is nothing
really new because like I get that they
were now Tom Warren came out it came up
with but it up was tweet or something
like that but I I remember at least a
one
maybe even to podcast where Phil Spencer
himself did say that they will have an
event before III know like it's not it's
now obviously he didn't specify when
exactly but the or III so you know right
now we're probably looking at like you
know as per the you know the the leak or
rumor in a lot similar april/may how
like you know I've I've heard that it's
probably it might be an April stuff but
I mean right right and I'm that's great
I mean because like you know I would
love them to finally like come up with
come out with all the spikes and stuff
whether you know like back in the days I
was like you know what I would love it
they you know work with digital foundry
again and yeah art yeah Richard like you
know he you know I love you know listen
you know I love how he he explains
everything and it's excited about
because let's face it now I get that
they will have like talking heads on the
show and stuff like you know I and they
trying to keep people hype and stuff
right I mean that's fine but you know
like it's totally different when you
hear somebody who really knows knows it
and then he can appreciate you know
things right because like most people
will just gross over the specs all
twelve teraflops thirteen that's fine
let's do it right you know end of story
right well he will they will really dive
and I'm sure they were like you know
once Microsoft comes out with over specs
and I'm sure that digital foundry might
will make like tens of videos about it
I'll probably make like you know thirty
videos about it and but the thing is
like you know I would love that and you
know those shows doesn't really excite
me that much because there's more
marketing yes II to be honest with you
so I would prefer like you know
something like that like like they did
with Xbox one eggs tomatoes to do at
this point I just want to know anything
right I mean I just want the facts right
you know whoever is going to you know
show it talked about it I just want
these specs out because let's say you
know with though some
those specs like you know leaks on
Twitter wrists there I'm reading I'm
like Jesus Christ who is it coming from
right where oh yeah I can't wait for it
right
I thought they all 3d audio and stuff
I'm actually interesting that's actually
interesting because like you know we
know that Xbox one and Xbox one X
already supports that right I mean the
3d audio game right so I'm kind of like
curious how how much better it's going
to be over yeah me too and and to this
point obviously PlayStation 5 is going
to be doing something similar because I
remember when mark Cerny was interviewed
by who was that what wired
wired yeah when they when they
interviewed him April last year he did
speak about you know 3d audio and he was
he did say that you know basically with
you know you know when when we were like
going from previous generations of
PlayStation 3 to PlayStation 4 there was
hardly any difference in terms of like
the audio stuff right we were still
using pretty much the same the audio is
pretty much the same so obviously you
know the same could could be said about
Xbox 360 and Xbox the PC and Xbox one
now so then you know comic you know come
up with this you know 3d audio support
and stuff for you know at least number
of games and stuff without you know
Dolby and that kinds of utmost and that
kind stuff right but I don't think they
have any like dedicated chip for it and
stuff right so when you're going to have
like you know hardware accelerated 3d
audio and stuff mm-hmm
I mean mark Cerny says that it's going
to be totally different experience right
so I can't buy it so that gets me
obviously excited so I just want to know
everything about both consoles yeah
which I'm gonna bring it back over to
let's go solve it cuz I'm curious I'll
get a chance to uh sovereign this you
know what do you feel about this
potential reveal of it you know being
April possibly coming after Sony's and
then obviously about the spatial audio
tech I mean I agree Mars completely I
want to see I think they
to get out their shoulder specs of the
machine at this point this back and
forth you know this game of chicken they
have with so with Sony doesn't really
matter because I think they're kind of
set on their price I think yes these
series X is gonna be five no and I think
you know and then somebody's gonna do
whatever they're gonna do a response to
that but in terms of the specs I agree
completely I mean it did them it did
wonders for the Xbox one X to put it in
digital foundries hands so I think
that's something they need to do before
hand as well just to get everything
about the console out there because that
III they won't how did they want games
game yeah facts I don't I don't even
know that they they might even keep well
again they might hold on to the price to
e3 and say yeah I think pricing game
should be the move right yeah but uh
yeah I think absolutely it needs to
happen I and I hope it does happen in
April and I hope they do go the digital
found throughout again cuz it did do
well for the series on for the Xbox one
X now when it comes to the spatial sound
like you know when we set out to
Plantronics and and mm-hmm
they do thing thing with them um were
able to you know be kind of on the front
lines when they started introducing the
headsets that had the yeah and um in
games that supported it it's absolutely
fantastic when you have a sound mix made
specifically for Atmos Wow
it is absolutely nuts and the way
they're able to simulate sound coming
from behind you above you below you with
regular set of headphones it's kind of
revolutionary right yeah so the only
caveat to that is that not every game
supports orts it because it's on the
software side and it's and it's
specifically from one provider right and
you have a license for it yeah it was
very hit a miss like again Gears five
gears five has a mix specifically for
Dolby Atmos and Intel when you play that
game nuts it's bananas so for them to
say just like Sony that they're going to
do it at the hardware level I think it's
fantastic is then you can slowed it at
the hardware level if you want something
to proliferate across the board
you you you baked it into the hardware
so that everyone has it who did that for
you in the chat just shut up the field
Dominus maximum expensive sir for for
showing his petty you know Sonny thought
they had a little one up that way but
you know shout out you know to fill
Dominus Maximus special showing its
petty letting people understand and know
their who's in control is eisah told her
the controller he's doing what you gotta
do put your headset we got that on day
it's in the box is it down to the chip
level so we were doing it before but now
we won't do it on the chip levels so
because you know people was you know
being lazy with the software now
implementing it how we wanted to
implement it so now it's gonna be there
fundamentally from the base so there's
there is you this is the equivalent of a
bully bullying a bully like you he is he
can't stop it's like every time he makes
a move you right they're like yeah we
got that too
you know you yeah it's like the
pressures on you know we just winner to
go reveal price they don't have they're
gonna keep strangling these news until
they talk first is not going to shows
and so far they pulled out of 78 of them
[Music]
how do you feel about this potentially
or April so Xbox reveal I feel like
people that didn't know this coming
wasn't paying attention
mmm-hmm it's pretty self-explanatory
this is coming you know definitely at
this point I will say Sony's definitely
bidding that need of Microsoft right now
they've let Microsoft take control of
the narrative currently because we've
got a whole bunch of super chests we go
get them I think you took it from them
and until Sony decides that you know
they want that narrative back you know
we're gonna have to see what Sony does
you know definitely have some bend the
knees in that chat for you know so deep
into the need a Microsoft cuz I do as of
right now so he's been in that need of
Microsoft Mac will put that up there
again look for the past like six years
Microsoft's bent the knee to Sony but
right now Sony has been in that knee to
Microsoft they allow any I'd be here
this entire narrative they're letting
not release stuff like right now
currently would you not say that and I
I'm firmly believe because Sony has
always been very reactive Oh Microsoft
you doing that when we doing this ever
since that series X was announced so
he's like oh do we got something you
don't okay we don't all right let's let
the raw budgets let's let them rock man
cuz you know it's like I said Saudi is
bidding that knee to Microsoft and I'm
completely 100% it's a lot of sauce a
virus bugs you know your out-of-pocket
brat with the Tyson chapter to get this
bods in the video and Pierre
pcmasterrace Christopher Hart Wow today
put it a colorful cake sony has money
and we'll flex when necessary please
tell them to start flexing because they
right now in my Saudi belong in the
bushes like right now
Sony gotta do something to make me think
that they they care because they
cancelling III events they've been
canceling they own event for like the
past three years
we don't even as of right now from you
know from nice experiences we don't know
if there
have they even at the end Alyssia addict
I gotta go home Marge we almost a March
and we still don't have a release date
for their reveal true Oh like come oh
wow let this go
people keep saying stuff like Sony's
still promoting stuff Sony still has
games to launch Sony ain't buy anymore
promoting their games so what are you
talking about these games
I'm Lamaze go for kids you know that son
is going to be at TGS because there was
this like you know you know TGS did you
know made the statement that the
next-generation consoles are going to be
there and hopefully fingers crossed
you know they will deal with you know
the coronaviruses stuff and you know
like you know it's going to be nice and
clean but you know with you I would
really love it Sony to like to make a
proper with anything like a proper
meeting a proper you know show for
PlayStation 5 and stuff so I wouldn't
know but maybe they could make some sort
of like state of play whatever to reveal
anything about lady has done this entire
generation but it's like it's like
solved this podcast I said it's very
many times the consumer is fickle don't
matter what you did for me the past six
years sure that can influence my
decisions but right now you show me that
you don't know what's going on Sony and
I have to be real so adding in the sake
of fair this year
you mean to tell me that when they not
drop it when they don't drop the
announcement forearm last of us or goes
to Shima and all this stuff that they
still got bangers left to finish to
jinhwan before they show a PlayStation
side they're there all I'm saying is we
have to admit they're in a position
where they are the market leader
they don't have to rush it let's be real
Microsoft got more to prove tip for the
next generation Microsoft you know until
we see a lot of stuff we need to see you
know these games they pop out which it's
like I said they're not gonna go through
so you know cities I could go for making
stuff like from outer world set the
record so I don't want that there to be
a Libra
because for a deaf ed people don't like
some people do not like ground it let's
keep it a buck okay it was calling a lot
of people like bleeding from the start
I don't like grounded I don't like this
but you know at the end we have to see
what the majority the studio is gonna
make I really don't like hell-blade I'm
going to try it again but we're not you
don't see the quality draw you know when
it comes the south part they made that
great game well what they made the
pillars of eternity I'm not the biggest
fan but apparently death would give his
kidney for that guy so they do have a
following you know we have to see we
have to see the the labor of that and
I'm completely a hundred percent but as
of right now mm-hmm it's like I said
this is fine I hope Microsoft ways to
announce price so you can see Sony dance
some more
let's just hope MIDI events they're
willing to pull out a way to go back as
I look bad yeah acting like oh man
that's before super check out the 108
dragon TV they say they played de cision
a seven yo shadow Sony looking like
Deontay Wilder right now no look no one
is saying that Sony hasn't proven
themselves but all I'm saying right now
is there's different factors and when
they
on that top of the game we have an
entire change of anarchy none of them
are pretty much exactly where they were
through the whole PlayStation 4 thing
you have a company that used to be on
top of everything Microsoft done and
they've went crickets for three months
so pretty neat a Microsoft I don't care
what you use you said this lends to the
credence of this is a whole new Sony I
mean when are we gonna realize this is
not the same dude he's just a kid
wearing Emperor's clothes Oh boots and
shoes too big the fill I mean you know
individuals that helped build the brand
are no longer there they formulated a
culture and it's no longer their
destruction and a hierarchy has changed
you know it would've been hella high
water for them to pull out of any of
these important shows a lot of times
they would never let a narrative rock at
all they will flat right yo you know
people are celebrating this game how
about this last was shrimp coming out
Thursday it looks weird and spooky to me
when you alone with Microsoft to fan the
flames and they're getting a bonfire
going and I don't know how you come back
for it when mod said that there be next
generation consoles that you said GDC at
EDC at the Tokyo Game Show and you gotta
say two names because a lot of dudes is
like oh you know you gotta say Tokyo
Game Show maybe it's just Microsoft
showing both consoles and so he's not
even there
you know the next-generation consoles
can consist of one company bringing
their consoles agreeing I don't believe
that
be realistic you like obviously this is
a fan thing you know we are tissa pating
we're not on Sony's time clearly Sony's
on Sony cool others Inc if you want to
add but you have to say gaming at it cuz
that's my name on here but okay let's
let's go into you know we we have went
what since November
Microsoft put out they chips like we got
they have never waited this long to
react to anything can I respond now
because you've been talking all right
all I'm saying is look I get it
everybody we want to see the show we
want to see the fireworks we want to see
my heavy weight matchup but frauding
dominated the last gen it's like yeah
dude you gotta get your weight up let us
finish and when we ready to start the
generation we can start it when we ready
they not on Microsoft's time everything
kognito say the thing is we could week
if Microsoft had not gone at the game
awards right we can sitting here looking
at neither console being tell that's why
they change the narrative but all I
which was fantastic by Microsoft that's
what they needed to do you punch them in
the mouth and you say yo this year is
different my guy I get where y'all at
all I'm saying is the showing start yet
and my thing is you're acting like if
these dudes do a surprise announcement
show the logo and show the system on
Twitter they can literally show the
system on Twitter the point every you
just proved my point
everyone is so thirsty we get mad at
look so deep it into me to Microsoft
saying that today live a bad lower
Carlito's dollar s+ level so deep OD you
know what
I think that list was onto something
it's like it's like Drake we can say
here be mad you know say that we get his
new album but we don't damn well we drop
it we copy like with the anticipation is
going to be high themselves in doing is
taking approach I don't Kings right all
I have to do is wait Sony has meant to
me because they relinquish the price
until they relinquish the price to
Microsoft Xbox is in position to set the
pace for the next generation
Sony losing spy you know I really really
think the different Sony and it has me
worried you know
but what I'm what I'm telling you is
this right I don't like I'm used to I'm
used to a company this company moving in
a different fashion and you know we we
joke a lot and stuff like that but I'm
used to when Microsoft makes the move
Sony is doing the bullying you know Sony
is mushing them in the face like we got
this and what I was what I keep saying
and I keep hearing that whoa you know
they didn't have anything to show does
that concern you like they pulling out
of these shows and they don't have
anything to show but nobody is ringing
Melissa King I wish you or the fact that
there are factors here that just say it
is valid right new leadership you
affectionately call them Sony I mean Jim
dance move rise we are seeing now I
agree to this point if they have not
acted like the typical Saudi we have
used to seen for the past generation
right which is tip for tack petty right
the Xbox Series X might Knight is scared
the but it caught them off-guard yes I
would agree with that
okay no weird in the middle but I'll
meet you I think that Sony's vegan
worried that King is worried like are
they okay the problem is that Microsoft
said they will be bold and they're
coming out throwing ball who's left
right and center and Sony just had their
ear trump on out bloody yo way do we get
what a wait we get old we got stitch
today she'll run to you by Sony soon as
the Saudi is the market leader so take
the damn lead
[Laughter]
we got JD after that you had the fun
Sony cannot will not reveal spec for
Microsoft and certainly not price they
are afraid of this Microsoft this
Microsoft is hungry bear and Sony is
lunch we will have to bend the need of
that super chair looking at it and I'm
seeing things and I'm just I'm just
shaking my head because normally certain
things should be I'm gonna tape you have
ghost of Tsushima coming and you have
lastly the best end of a generation we
like no or in the best beginning of a
generation right because right those
games and I'm sticking on this part I'm
not giving you my knees sovereign
because I believe that these games will
be back fully compatible only only when
you swipe the card you gonna have to buy
those enhanced versions of those games
they don't have I don't put it past them
I mean I don't but Kay but King but King
we can even if they don't have games we
could easily say yo they can make Last
of Us to add faction modes and a
multiplayer up res and charge dudes it
still be gracious to drop one
PlayStation 5 exclusive the rest cross
generational upgrade games of Last of Us
gosu Tsushima or whatever in dream so
they can really dream better real quick
let me get the last words I don't even
get a chance to talk about audio cuz
addict wouldn't let me finish but anyway
look I'm with mods I'm excited about the
tech you know like King said you know as
far as dolby atmos and stuff like that
like to me listen man that feature is
amazing when it's supported
it was probably some of the best things
that we have ever heard in gaming and
then I want to shout out how blade -
because I mean he'll play because he'll
blame it's the best use of audio I have
ever had it again and that was not using
at most if you're unsure if you have
mental issues playing the game for 15
minutes if you can't play yeah then you
might need to go get see so all it just
excites me for something like hell-blade
- could you imagine how blade - with
that level of audio for you know so
fidelity and just like the immersion
like there's so much to it so for me you
got I've played a lot of atmosphere
games a lot a lot in it miss fear games
and it was so real that I had to turn
the gas I still Street that game was
psychologically mess with so Noah's
voice it will message you so again that
wasn't even using at most back then so
now if they bake this in on the hardware
level like king is saying right well you
don't have to get you don't have to have
a dolby atmos license everything is
already in there if any and what screw
dope is any pair of headphones can have
this feature right yeah that to me is
super exciting the heart to me the
hottest features in next-gen is this
them CPUs with them frame rates Anka
because then I can get off my PC and
play destiny or what happened to an old
dog that you can't teach new tricks he's
arguing with so on ACEF they die and
they dance
say hello to dancing so d and he's too
uncertain 30 to be a better boy you want
to continue this fight you have to put
that in color
these colorful punches you need to step
your color game what I see JD gamer got
you in the bushes you need to go so
listen boss like I was saying for like
you talk about this type of audio tech
right you talk about SSDs faster you
talk about them
to use them frame rates you don't say
like this is why I was like this gonna
take me right you don't rate racing and
all that in these games with the nice
network infrastructure and I like Xbox
well now we talking baby now bhai
now I'm hyped for next generation I
don't know about you but but this type
of stuff this type of tech that excites
me are you hype for this or not to be
honest with you like I was actually
planning to upgrade my PC this year but
then once those like first specs for
leaked out about like 9 when there are
12 waps and stuff and all years these
and that kind of stuff you know what I
probably won't need a PC that's the same
yeah let me rephrase it
no it's not that I won't need a PC I'm
I'll still be using PC for backwards
compatibility other and you know
sometimes there's a great get deals only
on the only a cheap bastard
so I my games see so I'm not getting rid
of my PC and stuff I'm just not going to
spend any more money that's what I'm
saying because right at a $500 price
point that's this superior that see
cross so gamers a lot of men even used
to SSD what that does right there's so
many features that a lot of PC games out
to bribe everybody in here you know say
that all PC gave like you see that's why
it's so hard for us to be like your Abba
play that's the over there with you yeah
okay
you know say because we know what we do
it over yes Jonathan be I'm Millie
rocking
yours there because I know what that
level of fidelity and all that does so
now you put that on console with the
infrastructure that I like is my only be
four pcs I don't like their network
infrastructure
yo join my discord yo this game got
checked you know this game though that
check like I don't I don't like that I
like a simplified interface Xbox Live
see my friends live all in one jump at a
party chat window
on the Microsoft side of things we all
over there in your dashboard there's all
that stuff there because sinister
for the past we can have he has been in
my dams trying to get me over there to
the destiny
no more PC that's it I got a very nice
PC and you know what I told him I'm
waiting for the Exide see you next year
maybe later
because I'm not leaving my squad no man
left behind and I'm just not you a
better man than me was able to play you
know I play on my PC and I can play with
my xbox dupes if I can remove that whole
piece you still will have better than
those present next-gen consoles short
consoles will have ray-tracing the ultra
little buddy 2500 and it's better than
my rig right now
you know I'm saying it's gonna be better
than my rig I'm not doing it so give me
the 500 with the nice interface I'm
gonna be over here over here those those
muddy textures to play with my friends
in a place an environment uncomfortable
the only reason I want pcs cuz it's 60
frames you give me that on collision
we're gonna have to do this I want some
into the bushes for Bradford in that
chair out to my man mess he's like you
don't have to spend 2,000 on that I feel
you on that all I'm saying is but you
have to understand that there is an east
of use factor that a lot of people shout
out to my boy Ainsley who just picked up
his PC he's trying to do stuff driver
issues you know I'm saying oh I can't
connect I'm trying to fix this there's a
huge subject of gamers that don't want
to deal with any complications they just
want to press a button and it's born
that's it so that's what I'm trying to
say so if now my series XO my
playstation 5 is superior than my rig
which is better than a me then that
makes it easy for me if a 500 I mean
let's go when you have a you know I've
been in part COG what GPU do you have I
got
I'm nine CPU da Hye's Joyce every summer
whatever and I got a 1070 T I'm good
pocket watches exes smashing that so
let's go okay during a party with Xbox
Playstation people in the game crashes
they go at that game well this shouldn't
happen you're at a party with PC people
in the game crashes it's like it's
normal no oh man that sucks my going to
reboot it because it is normal kognito
how often do am i telling you man
destiny just crash you got to react and
my name is Martin why I got a joy 15
people discs or just a play like that yo
join my join the discord BTI a crushing
legend stop it starting you PC favorite
or
and I like PC first stop that we go get
to it but at the end of the day there's
a huge amount of people that don't want
to deal with PC issues let's get some
fraud shout out to PC for one they're
gonna move they're gonna move the
goalposts yet again very soon right
they're gonna you know you hear brad
talking about ampere ampere is real
right RTX 3000 series cards are real
they come there let's see how the last
point masks or understand the value
proposition here that's all I'm saying
that's for console guy if you buy two
next-gen consoles or more rights of one
of those cards short a what a man I
can't believe you quite a bit
you said you gonna turn your back on a
system that gave you all this German
over the last year in Lord listen I'm
going with the games that I'm gonna take
care of me brother that's where I'm at
you know Z and last I heard all
Destiny's got cross-platform play so I
could take my man whatever he over 37 he
said you could take that 500 series
accent upgrade what is nice
for you and you got a 20 70 GPU guess
what the rest of the world don't and the
rest of the world would like to pay five
hundred and not spend what you spent how
much you spend on the PC let's go people
gotta act like it's so funny like when
you got the bread and you could do
something you see I like do zakat
Braille told y'all that is the same
thing with the Sony thing and told you
when you got money you move in a
different manner when you're broke you
gotta say I can't go to this show we
have to acknowledge this and people were
talking about all these next-gen
consoles I have ray-tracing I have all
this stuff errors up there's a
performance cost to enabling all this
stuff right if if you don't want that
ray-tracing right I say they give you
the option to turn it on off per game
right your frame rates dropping you turn
it on your frame rates dropping so your
dreams of whatever 120 frames per second
say even 60 frames per second might be
in the bushes straight up so these are
things that people like when we talk
about the stuff blanket statements
across the board all these consoles
gonna have this yes they're going to be
able to do this mm-hmm there will be
costs
there'll be ramifications for doing this
so it's like the argument it's the same
argument than going on for decades right
and it's gonna continue to go on in the
same way right hmm the value proposition
is absolutely 100% there it really is
the thing is the PC the PC is the
platform that gives you the most options
period of course oh and I don't think
it'll never be when you do when you're
having this conversation but overall I
it never becomes the dominant platform
for that reason right people people
believe it or not when you get to a
certain point the less options you have
to mess around with stuff the easier it
becomes for you right if you that makes
any sense
like I like options as long as I can
just pick my option and put it to the
side and then the other things that I
get are locked off in a certain way
that's thank you for telling true braaap
did you spread 1300 for your PC thank
you for telling the true for your super
chair thank you
that's all I want to say he's with
thirteen hundred dudes Bobby spent five
and lap your PC crap we can't act like
these games aren't designed for console
13 for my PC I spent more buying a
launch Xbox and s and then attacks why
did you buy three we did it got that
brain without my credit cards do it oh
do it up that's all I'm saying is
there's people who look at a value
proposition to say hey I could get close
to that level well pass a lot of that
level for a different cog would have
definitely got the lowest spec phone is
the same thing he felt that his is there
right for the cheaper price so if you're
going to get the same quality for a
cheaper price or better quality for a
cheaper price why pay more rapidly
consoles acting like it's Xbox I bomb
like the rest Lords and I was like okay
I'm going to get a an a s what should I
get the plus or the s cogbi was like
don't get the Plus get the s cuz it's
the same phone he don't me that so I got
the city boys oh good
I know yeah I cut you off I'm sorry I
was gonna be a brat was fighting sorry I
catch oh and then we get we gotta move
good you talk about value proposition I
heard he was about to say some about PC
console thing so yeah because like you
know somebody started talking about the
ampere and stuff right I mean like yeah
those new cars are coming and stuff
right but like I've
rumors that the the ampere is is going
to be like you know 850 like square
something like that that's gonna be huge
huge so I mean oh the cheap is going to
cheap cheap going to be expensive the
cooling system is going to be expensive
etc so we're not talking about like you
know five hundred six hundred dollars
car probably a thousand maybe even more
because nothing how many how much Nvidia
is charging and the last point I wanted
to make about PC and splace which which
actually makes me sad because the thing
is like back in the days AMD was a very
was a you know I was a company that you
could actually you know pick up their
parts for very cheap I mean they were
not the best in terms of performance but
they were there and they were just good
enough to play I play the latest games
and that kind stuff right right now AMD
is actually moving towards kind of like
Nvidia approach to making business right
they are increasing prices they are
increasing margins and stuff they've got
better products for sure but you know
because of that because the fact that
they they find it good buy their
products they will charge you more
so CPUs motherboards GPUs all this stuff
is going to be way more expensive and
when even when we were like last word
even like two years ago when we were
like there was like a lot of come like
reports and articles comparing Xbox 1 X
2 PC builds and stuff and there and like
most PC guys couldn't build a PC for
less than $800 right so 800 versus 500 I
think like this generation it might be
something like 500 or 600 dollars a CD
sex and $1000 PC yeah well I gotta put
this fraudulent the whole time I read
this brat call I got five dollars
shipped out from brat cause more value
in my PC I can play games and do
spreadsheets
what are you playing bribery salute
salute the PC vast arrays Brad day out
he about him messing with peace
you either become whatever you find I
said quick question it's Carl often do
say because brat he says you can also do
your spreadsheets on a $500 PC and buy
two consoles and not have to worry about
driver issues and you know what's money
right he wasted his his characters in
that super check - Axew
that's how a PC Revis sister code ever
you say Cobb put me over here PC dock
you shave it before listen man I'll tell
you what the series X I just put y'all
on notice where I'm at the end of the
day crossways becoming more more
apparent it's looking like that's going
to be a future keeping pace I'm still
playing about x-series X but unless they
get the 21:9 ratio aspect ratio down
feat they need to have field of our few
slider I'm meaning PC and you said they
say no but i'ma tell you there's no we
go ahead as end oh there we go ahead at
SSDs gonna be better and we want a
graphics card so that's as well but you
don't you do you could use the Xbox and
you can use it on PC and you could join
my party
we need to bend the knee you know we
need to bend the knee for we need
ability for the old card - the new cog
2020 I'm different we got a boo-boo
we gotta move we gotta get into
vigilance this is you this is you addict
I hit the button already calm down I
like that you see it
so you know everyone in this chat
I'm sure because you know you keep that
you know you have your ear to the pulse
in this gaming community you guys know
what wouldn't it just said you know he
was he's tired of people using the term
it's just a game he did go out to make
some you know rather aggressive terms
and people that do use this so what I
want to bring to the realm is what do
you guys think what he said is true and
another thing is like do you think that
that term is used too loosely because
you know a lot of non-gamers do use that
term to attack gamers aim let's be real
here they do oh it's just the game why
are you playing that they do a lot of
people like to do this so I want to you
know bring that to the lords and see
what you guys think about this let me
get this cuz this will hit me different
um listen I get what he's trying to say
initially right I do get what he trying
to say look come on yo you know King
solve Kaiba to citizen in here channel 5
you know what we cut from right we cut
from them wrestling games that halo that
Tekken you know I'm saying that mo top
Slayer the competition with King beat
you he leave it with the belt you know
we did detecting the Iron Man best
attend until somebody mentally breaks
down friendships was lost halo with the
four TVs where the kicks understand Jeff
out the house you know saying like we
come is it from like they should
physical fights where it spills out
outside and we might not talk to you for
a few days
it's a we cool off Mario Party really
ruined friendships like I would I would
unplug in 64 controllers because I'm
getting whooping in Super Smash Brothers
mr. ha we come from the controller some
time after it was real like with Jamie
beat me one year and I was like I gotta
get my title back it was that level of
competition you know I'm saying so we
come from
you have to you have to explain the
Tekken thing the way we did the Tekken
right in order to determine rankings
right we already kind of went in with a
set thing of like who's better than
whatever and and the way it broke down
was usually like cog first I bought two
then my mother and it was like King and
King broke off a little bit and then we
had the thing is the way you determine
rankings was you had to beat the guy
that was vying for your spot you saw him
by 10 Massa we would do Ironman matches
think about what crazy we were and say
would not go home until the notches can
go all night until someone had a ten win
differential over the other / do you not
hard that like we took it it was a dojo
we had that we added to the point King
where dude used to pull up number one
solo brought his cousin to pull up on me
and say oh you nice a ticket yeah we go
go to the arcade right now we go handle
this but that's what way from so I get
the competitive aspect of what ninja is
saying and he said yo you don't want to
have that mentality however this is
where he loses me this is where he loses
me when he loses me is when you say okay
you're a horrible human being right yet
like you're a loser at life or whatever
because at the end of the day there's
just some people that's better than you
fan that's just good but let's just keep
it a buck this this did some things it
didn't matter how nice I got King was
winning with Goldberg in that way I had
the whole day like it just was my idea I
couldn't stand it but it just was what
it was but the same thing with me was
like y'all knowing that her egg come out
in the Gulf body with the Taekwondo was
in me I know when I was in my bag how it
was I saw again it's just we gotta be
careful with the disrespect of people
saying that yo you're a horrible human
being here there's your trash you know I
said sometimes a do could just
it really meant what he said I think
what happened is you know a lot of
people here don't stream i've streamed
to a point not a whole lot but backseat
gaming will frustrate you like there
ain't no way but he lost we shot that
shot to BP when you compare it to tom
brady and sam you pick it up a kajillion
to enough in athletic stop you go up to
Tom Brady just after he lost the yes
mentally yes you know right after he wad
he's walking in he's like dude it's just
a game it's not just a game we just lost
the Super Bowl from that perspective he
didn't mean it like you know any kind of
you know sports related thing I
struggled with the comparison I giving
about yourself I can start with the
comparison to someone who's an athlete
right physically playing baseball boxing
MMA whatever whatever they're picked up
we really compare you know people you
know the sports athletic people they
train all year round for theirs warns
you know ninja he plays for tonight
hours upon hours and when you get to
that high competitive thing and you lose
that because let's be real her knee just
almost every time ninja is put in
position where he has to you know he
chose let's be real
he's get tired of people man that jab
you like it's just the game because I
don't know if you've got seen ninja flip
out but it ain't fun it is definitely a
different aggressive level when he loses
that I've ever seen any professional
athlete exactly that's a thing like it's
different for him mistake so different
this is his livelihood right so to have
when you talk about that competitive
nature once you have that extra level
put on to it where now this is how you
live when I record of how much money he
makes
look beats games life
not in the Super Bowl he's just playing
for playing for tipsy claim to
recognition he's playing in that stream
that most of us make in a year
the final as they said don't let these
kids go down and wrong path
my cousin threw my controller one day
and broke it I proceeded to put his feet
on that man I wish I grew up without yo
fam squirrely it was real bad gas off
the thing is my thing is like guys you
don't look at what you put down on
Twitter like why do you how do you I
don't I don't like retweeting like I
don't look at what you put down like
obviously in the moment you do it you
know messed up it was funny
not only does he he records it and I'm
tree watching the free uploads it and
then he uploads it so it's even twice as
bad like the other day I agree what you
said ninja I do but you cannot go as far
as after that and saying everyone's a
loser I don't even think you necessarily
he was thinking people that mentality or
losers I think he was having that
mentality like if you don't have a
competitive sport you're always gonna be
a loser and I think he said it in the
wrong terms and that's why you know
people attacked him over you have to
like do you are in a giant bigger on
Twitter you have to be more even if you
feel that way for real yeah you can't
tell somebody oh they'll lose and so if
that's something that he said don't
don't backtrack off of it stand on your
sweat if you thought that the dude is a
lose their life for going at you and you
feel that you win and stand on your
square but if you're not willing to
stand on your square and back those
words up don't say them don't tweet them
don't put them out there but that's the
thing he didn't say if he said it
directly to the dude and they had that
interaction back and forth cool he made
a general statement about that he's a
period
individuals and like I said pride before
the fall usually happens all right but
we also got a look at the longevity of
these streamers we don't know we can't
quantify how long they got we can
quantify how long football players got
and how long baseball players got and
stuff like that we can quantify that
because there's a formula for this
formula right now is uncertain so he
doesn't know how long he got he doesn't
know if he has a year left in this he
doesn't know if he has six months left
in this he doesn't understand when it's
over but when it's over it's very hard
for a lot of these youtubers femurs
dudes to recover because they didn't go
down to a different pattern not saying
I'm doing weirdo things like old ninja
doing something else what reality show
you know so he's staring at his
mortality to be honest with you so he
doesn't know at that point in time if
let's say he'd lost a match right he
doesn't know if that is the the the
trickle in oh what's going to lead up to
next because it takes domino effect yeah
it takes one cuz you didn't tell me some
dude beat him and it was horrible like
well addict told me it was he said oh no
that dude like beat him and I said you
know in that yeah in that area times you
know I have to give the respect because
a lot of people don't like ninja I don't
really care to like him or not like him
like he's just some person that plays
that's really good a fortnight and I
hate fortnight so I won't really matter
but I'll again you know I got a receipt
Tim because he is one of those people
that he didn't go out and get a coke
addiction when he started getting money
like he legit I don't notice no detail
on his life like the dude and fast right
like he's gonna come out put coke on the
table just I can't say for sure and he
didn't get an addiction or whatever what
I can say is this right I must say this
part oh I like his moves
yeah like so moved at him getting a bag
he stepped away from one place to go get
a bag going over because the MA
for the dude is very short right no how
long he got so what he's right
capitalizing on his thing but when he
says somebody's a loser at life this is
the mentality of these individuals right
now right no but this has been going on
don't be hating did you win him in life
I think he's burned he in all sense he
after this mixture thing happens because
I'm assuming he had he's obligated to
stream I'll make sure even if he quit
what so I'm assuming after this mixture
deal is over
I think he's out like he's a live stream
and I got no hate for anybody building a
brand and the success the man has that's
not where I'm at where I'm at is again
horrible human being and then you're
calling these people lazy human beings
like anytime you put yourself up on the
line
ain't no laziness with that you don't
say to men stepping away ain't no
laziness that pause he lost me with that
you never say again you know I
understand the point that's something
that you would expect cutie pie you a
cornball I'm saying this is cornball
will do gotta be more selective what he
says and he can't be saying he thinks we
move on man dreams solve let's wrap it
up yeah real fast man roof this is what
they did they buried the dreams the
dreams gets the shallow grave I didn't
mention it to Jason last week but I
would have liked to be known if he had
played it what he thought about it um so
I mean from from the perspective of
product right I know usually when a
perspective of just a product right it's
difficult to quantify what dreams is
right it's a creation suite basically
and what they've taken what they did
with LittleBigPlanet independent
Media Molecule and just sort of blown
that out to make this super
comprehensive and relatively easy to use
creation suite in addition to allowing
you to see like and download people's
different creations which is what I've
done right
I don't I'm not really interested in
making anything but I wanted to support
it because you don't really see this in
the game space a lot anymore just uh
yeah well that's the thing and what
happened to project spark right it was
something that wasn't working out
precisely because dreams is gonna fade
well this is the thing and this is why I
said I kind of agree with you right I
think as a product I think it's
fantastic that it exists I think it's
fantastic that Sony supported them to
this point um but and shout-out to Colin
Moriarty because he's been talking about
this for a very long time like I don't
know who it's for and I don't know how
it makes money everything so I'm saying
going in the bush is going to the bush
see this is what yeah I rather talk
about to talk about dumb ass ninja in
whatever games whoo Oh games and and
dreams and but this is the thing I don't
want to support because I know
regardless of the 9091 Metacritic mm-hmm
you can't deny it
you cannot not it this is almost 40
reviews okay okay let me ask the check
every one of the chat that bought dreams
or plays drains put a 1 everyone that
didn't buy dreams or not playing dreams
put it to I'm with you you arguing with
yourself no one's arguing I just want to
see the chat reaction that move to make
something right I'm not arguing I just
want to know what the chats playing or
not that's all I'm talking about I'm
talking that I literally just want a
chat engagement and put a cherry lime
but I'm talking about the creative
aspect of it and you're immediately
talking about I said nobody's laying it
right
he's agree with you KATUSA at the end of
the day I don't know who is for the
community everything all of it is
fantastic
I don't know who is for I don't know how
it makes money they tried to get they
were trying to get like real developers
to actually make games in dreams to sort
of bring up popularity for it nobody's
really biting nobody like your engine we
don't like the Metacritic phenomena is
it doing really well have to do the
Metacritic is the scores of the there's
a strong chance that this has the
highest Metacritic out out of any of
their exclusives this year Wow tell you
i'ma tell you this right now that's the
last of us which is going to rub some
people the wrong way i'ma tell you why
many people who feel that game did not
need a sequel and if to doesn't live up
to about live up to if it doesn't pass
the first one mm-hmm pay for it in
scores I'll tell you that that is true
if it feels like a cash grab what a
statement is a statement is saying that
it was an all incumbent story even if
you know they had the DLCs and stuff
like that it was all incompetence it was
done now to expand it now it just seems
like mmm it's kind of I don't know I
don't know how they gonna do it I don't
know we're gonna go with it I don't care
I just like that game so when it does
come I'm gonna support it I'm gonna
get it whatever they do release you know
the release date or the price point on
whatever they do whenever decide to talk
about their games games or be someplace
where I can get my hands on this game so
I don't know like I think he's onto
something to be honest out the stitch
with the file I super jet dreams is what
you do when you drink half a bottle of
nyquil bushes if you got a controller
let's do a bars into half this up but
I'm gonna say this I don't want to hit
ponies out here it's funny cuz nobody
wanted to rough this game 91 on
Metacritic and AH dreams
fraud's net frauds frogs no frauds
rewarding support just like the way
you're supposed to support concrete
genie come on guys dream just like Honey
I Shrunk the Kids
it's a passion project for medium what
else is Meeta molecule making right now
brat anyway what else are they making
right now that this would be their
pressure project to compare to that game
amazing this day project project what do
you think about yeah I mean I mean
dreams I would I would I would say that
it's a game I mean I know that it's not
like a proper game mm-hmm
you know I would not consider that as a
professional tool for developers right
and like you guys mentioned that you
know Sony was trying to or medium a
medium molecule was trying to do it you
know as a tool for developers who
created games I think I look at it as
like you know basically project spark -
yes right
I mean that it's only you know now
here's the thing now how they could
actually make money on it is that you
know if Media Molecule
you know basically suits to you know
stay and still sport the game I mean
like you know that
not really a game right but if they if
they like if they use it right if they
imagine our dedicated team why that
would actually put like quality content
right and maybe monetize it somehow they
could actually make some marcona almonds
let me ask you this question I don't
think that you know like you know fans
creations are going to be enough to
really sell this this is where I bring
in the smoke that these guys like
talking about right in the new the way
we've talked about Sony looks different
now right does new Sony have space for
just passion projects like it's
supporting it like if you think about it
dreams came out fantastic
critical reception not a single
advertisement not a single commercial
and this is something that it's funny
the developers themselves talked about
the game and said well this is a game
that it gets his popularity from word of
mouth right but how do you not have an a
commercial on TV for a game that that is
this critically praised right you why
would you not want to put it out there
right that's one
secondly why would you not put this game
on PC day and day this is there's any
game that should be on PC if there's a
community that likes messing with stuff
like this it's a piece a sodding IP on
PC day and date you trying to blow the I
wasn't gonna bring this to the table
without a little bit of smoke
super fans can create the PlayStation 5
reveal I am I'm sure like because of the
long sort of beta period and whatever
like there's thousands of creations in
there some you know I want a graphic so
what do you feel about this you know I
didn't purchase it all right I'm not
into making games for somebody else
yeah just a game to play a game I don't
purchase a game to make a game for the
community he's like this is this is
Sony's way of stealing your ideas I'm
looking at this whole thing and I'm just
like wow they really did this and they
could have put it as something free
because wasn't um project spark like
something free yeah like you got cancer
I think the actual official launch was
supposed to be actual price though no
but it was it was some you know side
project thing that they had over there
and it was like yo check this out and
you know mess around with it and I think
that was something that they could have
put date and date inside a PlayStation
now they get you into PlayStation now
[Music]
shops like that yeah we best of shrew
Kingdom got it I think coronavirus to
market
[Music]
it's not for me you know we know it's
nice is creation you know I want to
shout out will me and them I was with a
podcast me talking about it but I have
no patience for them these games like
all that cleaning tools stuff it's not
for me they're you know you know what
the best I did King remember that game
fighter maker I took that game back that
same day I'm never gonna forget that you
decide so hard
[Music]
I think I took that game back the same
day too I remember opening the case
right and you know back in the day when
you still have pamphlets right pamphlet
for this game over the size of the Bible
quick story got all the school's the you
know he promotes relentlessly he can ace
a into a yes man any second and this is
when cash is at a premium right we go in
and we all plunk down off I think was
like 50 bucks 50 for that yes we got it
we all got home and car goes his way we
all go our own way I got it home right
back to the store I told him was
something wrong with the dish my joint
for whatever game came out over the car
and I'm like yeah with you were you
doing he says yo I got the leg the move
so he got this dude in his fighter
stance so it automatically like had a oh
oh right so he did that but then he said
let me show you the kick in the leg
kicked out it did it came back I said I
wanna see how long he's gonna stick
around
he snuck around some months with me the
thing is the leg didn't kid normally
right cuz in the game came with
simplistic right so it didn't account
for like for like 3d space right leg
kicked out and it came back the leg like
the polygon went inside of the other
policy like a leg sticking out and then
retracting sticking out of the fighter
make it oh Jesus
the original dreams that was the best
III tried oh yeah babby look salute the
James do it well you know obviously this
is gonna probably spawn some future
creator you know they remember to do
what do we do you said no no I just said
that dream rights born somewhere I look
down at this detects that you remember -
I remember I gave fight Omega what was
it what was it and I remember they have
RPG Maker to shout the father big if
y'all remember that game and I would
that was my OG with that but yeah but I
was there man but these this is what
this is this is you know these guys
being creative someone will create this
the stuff people are creating in this
joint it's really crazy I see somebody
do spider-man and already ghost of
Tsushima it's one of those things like I
don't know you know structured now I
don't understand like they may turn
around and I think calamari already
worried about is that they shut Media
Molecule down because at some point
Metacritic aside like if you're not
selling and you don't intend to sell
this and find a way to sell this then
what is the purpose right and it was
powerful by them and if it's not in like
a like Matt said if it's not a robust
enough engine to really be viable as a
game creation engine right who is it for
it is it's very weird that they allowed
them it's almost it's almost as if
Microsoft had it would have allowed them
to finish runescape
well no poor we all because the Lord's
will be at PAX next week there will be
no Pope but we want to shout out the
team man you know super hike for the
weekend super high all the lords lords a
game in that net will be out there full
effect Home & Away teams we got ton of
coverage for you guys
tons of stuff arm children please check
out four Lords of gaming dinette we will
be out there starting Wednesday so again
there will be no ILP on Sunday but I
want to shout out the team Laura Bob
done old school style my boy Lord gene
or macho sir now though of course Lord
High you don't say and of course a guy
I'm bringing we got to horse with me a
king rolling no they're too hard I'm
pulling up you know I'm saying but um
y'all appreciate everybody like that's
that's gonna support and we're looking
to get some really really cool things
for you do we get brat with this chat oh
my god do we get ready we miss that
bread with your dreams creating more
bangers in Xbox one I am out PC
master-race salute Lord Lord Shang Lord
shine collector hasha
III hashtag mods time to upgrade that
GPU hashtag calm on their Sony Baro
[Music]
salute the Bratz be a pedi get the last
word but we're gonna be out there you
are looking very excited about so King
anybody wanna get at it we're fine fine
she was going on can find me on a
Twitter
first off you know we had like 250
people I want to thank everyone everyone
hit that like button we definitely
appreciate in a way you know subscribe
for you know we do this every week you
know we're gonna have a lot of content
for you guys next week with the Lords
whole not going to packs but you helpin
you help them with team waiting but wait
team is open definitely want
every one of you all the members all the
super shadows all the people just
watching we do this every week for you
guys
absolutely shout the Lord mods pulling
up in the round dealing with the Twitter
controversies of the coronavirus and I'm
glad that we had a respectful discussion
even though we like different sizes
cool man bar just go away kill five
people five well we can find me on
Twitter amaz gaming pho and YouTube mods
gaming and otherwise always nice to be
here you know talking about yes
technology wise you see all that gear
click his name see all that gear that
lore Cognito got on all that nice
merchandise there's the shot so who used
to do it on DJ sing hope he's okay we
ever heard from a little while ago he
was doing so well
Lord solve with the smoke today this is
[Laughter]
IOP on twitter and being sovereign on
PSN xbox live yeah man are really sad
not to be able to go to PAX East this
year
[ __ ] was fantastic interviewing
different people the PAX East show floor
is like nothing no no other sort of
event oh I just want to say I'm so proud
of you guys man everything that's been
accomplished the past year I'm so mad at
myself for not being able to be there
but you'll be back yeah man I hope you
because of facts yeah sexy biscuit proud
of you guys man I know you continue to
do great things I can't wait to see what
comes down to pipeline this week because
everything oh no I think this was the
most anticipated combat talk I have ever
seen I've never seen dude stay and not
like this this was like move on Lawrence
we need to talk to King today you did
really good numbers you know that's the
nice thing about it and but it was
highly anticipated the fight was highly
anticipated and and also I was talking
about it on Twitter
um and then that note I want to go to
side borders thank you much for coming
through my man yeah we catch you in Cali
we definitely but Michael Hollow Metheny
yeah a lo Fallowfield halluf ID TG
follow him on Twitter he put a very
poetic tweet it was a series of tweets
oh I'm not gonna get a chance to go into
reading it but go follow him so you can
see these series of tweets and it
eloquently put the whole fight in
perspective you understand and they
talked about the king and a horse what's
the difference between a king and a
horse
and it is a very good read if you get a
chance to read that um so let's get to
this part right here because I
understand I see the red right and you
see the red behind me this statue is no
careless is gonna come out on Monday
because we're gonna be a pax and you
know it's not gonna be a kos this week
but this statue is by Mark Brooks and it
shows Scarlet Witch in oh yeah get a
chance to go look at on past Kara let's
go to Lords of gaming dotnet things the
old episodes of ILP also Kos also combat
talk and also the last word also many
pieces also reviews hard game reviews
with addict there's a whole lot of stuff
at the website and when you actually get
that you're gonna see it's very very
well written
I mean this is just stuff there boy I'm
telling you I get lost in it sometimes
and I just have to back out of it
because my dad go past but um I can't
wait this week guys I really can't wait
this week because we make our bones
impacts and we respect packs
unlike Sony we respect we respect you
know because of the corner virus
whatever virus they pulled out for I
think with the pocket eating virus they
pulled out but we'll beat it
gloves on will be there who you guys
breathing breathing all that stuff to
bring you their information to give you
what y'all actually for and also if you
if you join the realm if it's the first
time you hear this bill like oh my god
so we do this every week if you join the
room you hit the joint button we're
going to be releasing a lot of those are
videos of those games from pax next week
early for you guys yeah we're also gonna
do a show
in the middle of the week for you guys
for ILP a real you know quick take like
we did last year when you're not a
chance to see my man change so hopefully
we see somebody of that ilk this week no
but I'm really proud of the team I'm
really proud of everything going forward
and this stuff is mapped out guys we are
giving you a road map to where we're
going forward with this yeah absolutely
make a connection about it again like
you said super proud man Lords gaming
down now I want to shout out the
editorial team as well you never say a
shout the dizzy CEO oh shut up tonight
editor-in-chief Josh
ready but the website we go man of
course undead tweet XB i you know i'm
saying huge all these guys contribute
you know and we're getting that cadence
that the quality content and because of
the hard work of these guys the writers
you don't say a shout out to all the
riders from lords of gaming that net
because of that quality we're able to
you know go as media and provide you
guys coverage so we're super proud of
that we gonna try to do the best job
you're doing ask the great questions we
can get try to get the latest games and
we got some oh my god the games that we
see in we're super excited man so we
want to look out for that support us
anything else attic you got before we
rock on out of here
it's salute everybody supported a new
intro an attic holding down with a cold
most on that you know I'm saying graphic
God did a phenomenal job we like that
you guys like it and we'll be adding
more things and make a little tweaks and
stuff more animated emojis we're gonna
try to get who did that for you we're
gonna try to break it all looking at our
IOP Twitter in the description for that
be sure to follow us on Twitter because
we're gonna be making announcements when
I finalize a couple things but the week
after next show everybody enjoy and stay
tuned the Lords of gaming doubt neck you
gonna see a lot of fly this up on that
and on the channel so I'm out of here
everybody join your Sunday please
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]